mlops short for machine learning
operations refers to the practice of
applying devops principles to machine
learning this mlops course will guide
you through an endtoend mlops project
covering everything from data ingestion
to deployment using state-of-the-art
tools like Zen ml ml flow and various ml
libraries IU sing developed this course
he has created many popular machine
learning courses on our Channel this
course will teach you fundamentals of
emops as well as we be having one end to
end project which will involve from data
ingestion to deployment using several
state-of-the-art tools like MLF flow
zenel and Etc mlops is completely new
field and there are very less resources
around it and this is a gold mine and a
game changer in the ml Community if you
do this with the dedication and the
patience you will be able to succeed in
learning about mlops and then you will
be also getting the international Pace
or whatsoever job offer which you want
in your hands but but wait who am I I'm
lead data scientist atate I've L several
products in crea's economy along with it
I have worked as a emops engineer as one
of the fastest growing emop streamwork
which is zml and have experienced in
working as a data scientist at artifact
and building large scale NLP products
before even GPT was launched and
hopefully by all of this experience I'm
the right guy to teach you about mlrs
all the required links and everything
resources is listed down in the
description on boox below you can go
ahead and check that
out
hey everyone welcome to the another
lecture on mlops we'll be starting off
with giving you a slight introduction to
mlops also I'll make you aware with the
terminologies of mlops which is very
important for you to understand the
later content of this course as well as
we'll also make sure that you understand
the basic things like pipeline steps
which is a library which we'll be using
out there but before that we'll make
sure to that you understand why there's
a need of mlops what like what are the
stages and envelops and etc etc so let's
get started with this uh lecture so the
first thing first so the first thing
first out is um about t the the growth
of data is increasing there's
exponential growth of data and the
importance of artificial intelligence is
also has also increased over time now
the data has increased but now we need
to make sure that we utilize that data
in a right way and in a positive way
right so that's where it come that that
that's where we we have artificial
intelligence right so now you might be
thinking that okay fair enough we can
just build a prediction model on top of
it but you should understand that
machine learning is not just about
building model why I say this why I say
this because your ml code or whatever
Machinery model is just 20% of your
whole machine learning project or a
whole um business problem right there's
a lot of things which comes into that
place and your machine learning code is
just 20% out of the whole set of things
so I hope you will I'll prove you why
why there's a 20% of ml code throughout
this video and it's ml in the industry
is more than the training models it is
validated by chip Huen who is one of the
ex experts in mlops and it is also
validated by Elon Musk who just said
yeah it's like machine learning
engineering is just 10% machine learning
and 90% engineering and that's something
really interesting to worry about and
you might be thinking that every other
courses online teaches only about
machine learning engineering which is a
building machine learning models but
nobody teaches about the engineering
part of it right and you might be
thinking it might be some data
structures on algorithms or it might be
some design patterns or Etc of course
yes it has some factors but there are
lot more than these DSA and stuff which
will explore throughout the course
through our
project
so we uh in a typical ml team uh in our
corporate we have the following uh
people who are actually responsible for
doing x amount of tasks so your data
scientists discover the raw data develop
features and train models right and data
engineer who productionize the data
pipeline we'll talk about the term uh
productionize in a Bild but data
pipeline is like where the data is
coming from and then making it on a
large scale right and then we have a ml
engineer who sits on front to deploy the
model right so that it can be used by
users by you we'll talk about what does
deployment mean in just some seconds and
then we integrate the service into into
your website or application and then you
have to monitor it we'll talk about each
and every steps in grade detail and then
you have a lawyer who who can just ask
you we we should ask question to them
can I use this data for my model yes or
no and and I'm pretty much sure that you
might not be aware with any of the any
of the red line over here I'll make sure
that you understand each of the things
like training models productionizing
deployment integrating monitoring and
all the stuff throughout this int
introductory lecture the reason why I'm
doing this introductory lecture to make
sure that you understand each and every
bit in the project which will use which
will make use of like terminologies
which will make use over
there so what data science actually sees
you might be thinking about okay fair
enough you have pd. read CSV you read
the data you fit and then some some
happens and then you simply uh and then
you also have the classifier you also
fit that and then you do predict and do
score right that's what you see right
but do you really think that uh by
writing three these three lines of code
people will get your job of course not
right and the main focus 90% focus
should be on engineering and what
engineering sees is much more uh very
scary than what data science
is so ml in production you might if
you're a bit aware even about how does
it goes Etc the first step is you
collect the data you train the model and
then deploy the model introduction what
does deployment mean so let's talk about
a little bit about deployment so that
you understand it a bit however I
recommend if you want to understand
deployment much more in great detail
we'll have more sections on afterwards
to actually understand what does
deployment mean over here so deployment
means that you once you once you have
the trained model for example let's take
an example you're you're working on a
email spam detection project right and
the model is currently is in a local
server right is in a machine how can you
use that and integrate into that Gmail
right so that that we can use that model
to make predictions for the users who
who are who are whom for for whom we are
making this model for right and that's
where deployment comes in right
deployment is about that you have to
make your local model available to the
lot of people to the users for which
you're building the model
for right that's what deployment means
you to deploy the model online and and
we'll see we'll talk about on deployment
in very great detail in some
time but you might be thinking that this
is the process but what ex actually it
looks like so basically what happens
that first of all you collect the data
you train the model and then you deploy
the model now once your model is
deployed you again go back and collect
in the data and then training the model
and this Loops goes in environment but
how does you how how can we say how can
we say that that okay the what's the
loop is about you might be having
several questions what is the loop what
is the production environment and lot of
things out there so let's talk about in
great detail about what does the loop
means and what is the production
environment
is so I'll take a very very simple
example of uh this image right so for
assume that you have you had the
collected the data and then you had to
trained the model and then you deployed
the code right so assume that assume
that it is deployed in production your
spam production St spam production
system and is being used right now what
happens that you changed your model you
changed your machine learning algorithm
from logistic ration to n base right you
changed your ml algorithm right so you
have to you have to retrade go back to
the model and then and then whatever is
change you have to again deploy that
changed model which is update the model
right which is one case is different
model needed or ml algorithm changes
right another another point is for
example you're building some span
reduction project you might have trained
it on a on a on a data set which which
is which which might be unupdated right
or a new data arrives right for example
your hackers or spammers change their
strategy of sending spam emails right so
so the the the data changes and your
model should be able to identify the new
patterns which the spammers are
following right so what happens that if
any data changes happen it retrains the
model so first of all data again new
data comes in retrains the model and
then deploy it that's why we call it in
a loop in a production environment it is
a NeverEnding process you know it is a
never- ending process deployment goes in
production right and it trains the model
it it sorry uh it first of all collects
the data trains the model and deployment
goes in production what if if your model
changes model changes if the model
changes you again you have to go back
and then push it again or if new data
arrives you have to go back to data
collection and then push it
again I hope this really makes sense if
it does not don't worry we'll have uh
lot of examples to study more I'll take
I'll give one possible scenario of this
production when ml algorithm changes or
of the about the loop in a production
environment so one possible scenario of
going back of of going back is about
model performance starts to Decay right
so once you train the model you deploy
it after a certain period of a time your
model starts to Decay so let's take an
example of a fraud detection example so
assume you have trained your model for
fraud detection and let's say you have
deployed it as well and you see your
model is giving incorrect prediction
right so it most probably happened that
your frauders change the strategy or
patterns to fraud right the the patterns
which your machine learning algorithm
has learned has changed so you need to
recollect the data and retrain the model
which means go back and then do it again
and it may happen after some some time
again hackers change the strategy right
so this is what the model performance
starts toate then you have to go back
into the loop and then uh retrain and
redeploy them more another scenario can
be we might need to reformulate the
problem as it difficult to get gathered
data more data as we need so reformulate
other problem s violation of assumption
which we made during training so
basically what happens basically what
happens when you train the model we have
certain assumption for our input data
that the the input data will be in
certain range or input data will will
will will be there are a lot of
assumptions which comes into this place
so if the if the Assumption changes if
the assumptions changes which we had in
a training data we might need to uh
reformulate the Assumption or maybe go
go back to this and have those
accommodate the Assumption which are
being violated or simply the business
objective changes and basically to
restart again so a lot of things which
comes into that place which can be of a
loop and it is never ending process you
have to have continuously um seeing your
model monitoring your model and stuff so
ml production which is data affects the
output system and it's very hard to make
it reliable when deploying model
retraining and then collecting and then
the loop is very very hard to make it
reliable and that's where mlops comes in
place mlops is a set of practices it is
not some library or it is a tool it is a
set of practices that aims to deploy and
maintain machine learning models in
production reliably and efficiently so
to make sure that if there's anything
changes in the data it retrains the
model I'm just taking one one or two
examples it rechange the model if the
assumptions are violated it again goes
back so we have to make a reliable
production I which is which is happening
at a large
scale so uh the term mlops is like the
extension of the devops methodology to
include machine learning and data
science assets at the first class
citizens within the Devol ecology I'm
pretty I'm pretty much sure that that
you might be a bit uncomfortable with
this so let's try to think about in
another way okay I'll tell you a very
simple example of mlops so assume that
you you are you are given a a game to
build a beautiful city right now you
just build the be now if you build a
beautiful building in that city is that
helpful just write yes or no is that
helpful yes or no building a beautiful
city in that build uh in that city is
not at all good thing because it needs
the electrical connectivity it needs the
maintenance it needs the security
systems it needs the connection to the
roads and the railways and lot of things
which comes into the place right right
so a single building is like a is like a
model you have to connect it you have to
securitize it or you have to monitor it
there a lot of things which comes into
that place for making the fully
functional City and companies wants what
companies wants the full Standalone
cities not a full building right and
that's where the people are not getting
jobs it's only because they are only
focusing on building that building not
the whole city and mlops is a way to
building that that full city which is
required so we really talked about
deployment but you might be thinking
it's very very easy to deploy the model
in production but let me tell you that
the trouble begins after deployment so
you might be worrying about why so I'll
tell you what are the some of the things
which needs to be taken care of the
first one is accounting for latency so
what is latency latency is about that
that you might be shocked by the
statistics that 53% of the visitors are
abandoned if a mobile site takes more
than 3 seconds to load so for example if
your sites take more than 3 seconds to
load 53% of the people will abandon the
site and you know why and I'll tell you
why is because for example you have you
might have deployed a 120 billion
parameters model or a very large model
do you think that model will give
prediction in less than 3 seconds that's
that's that's really hard right and
latency is one of the biggest problem
right and if visitors are not VI your
viewing a model or a website they most
likely not is engaged with a brand and
they most likely not buy your product or
utilize that
product right so this is one of the
those another one is that fairness right
so for example you deployed your model
right so basically what happened that
Microsoft created a Twitter bot to learn
from users and you know it became the
racist it started supporting the various
bad ideologies after deployment they
thought that this will be so good and it
was taken down by Microsoft in just some
hours it was against feminism it was
sorry it was against um I I'll not take
any names it was against x amount of
thing right which was which was which
was so racist out there that's why they
had to take it down in matter of some
some some some hours after deployment
they thought that this will be good but
but eventually it learned very bad
things and then need to retrain it but
however it never gone into production
from from
there another one is lack of
explainability and audibility it's very
hard to explain the prediction right um
and and and and we also also have to
make sure that it is authentic enough to
trust this right and that's why there
are several rules and guidelines which
are coming by and by again to make sure
from the U EU to make sure that we fit
some of the principles of
AI and it is painfully slow I'll tell
you 36 the there was um basic you know
um survey conducted from a set of data
scientists about how much time they
spend in deploying and machine learning
models 36% of them said said that they
spent a quarter of their time which is
36 % of their time deploying machine
learning
models right and and and this is so you
know um um which is and and and they're
like more 36% of S quarter to half of
the time of deploying and 20% half to 3
quars and 7% in more than three quarters
it is very very slow and you might be
noticing why it is slow and there's a
lot of things which will will face when
when when we are building project we
might be very surprised so to see that
I'll be I'll be so correct to you I'll
be so truthfully to you that when I was
building projects for this course I
actually spent my whole week in
deploying models because it's painfully
slow and and you and you might be
shocked that I built the whole ml model
Tor procing in just two days that's it
and spending four hours but a freaking
whole week in deploying
it so this is uh this is one of the so
yeah so um so I'll talk about the model
Centric and a data Centric in a b but
what exactly model Centric and data
Centric means so model Centric means
that you are you want to improve the
model while do not changing any data so
you fixed the data so you have X amount
of data you fix it and then you
iteratively improve your code or model
by tweening it some parameters and
expect your model to perform well or in
data Centric what you do you hold the
model fixed and then you keep on
iteratively improving the data
and a lot of work is in this model
Centric only few of the work is in data
Centric so I suggest for you all to
focus on data Centric more probably to
focus on data have still the model but
yeah it's to totally upon your choice
this is also Sav by Andre d which is
again the very U Pioneer which is one of
one of one of my instructor too is's
very nice in what he teaches and I think
that his ideologies I was in one of the
webinar of him and actually he told
about this B Centric and data Centric
and which which we really experience in
our day-to-day Life as a data
scientist so let's get started with
talking about the whole process of mlops
and what does it include so the first
thing to worry about it what is the
business problem we want to solve so
what is the business problem we really
want to solve that's the first question
to start off so any melops project any
machine learning product which we have
to start first to worry about not about
what Pro what what exactly ml thing
would you have to solve what business
problem which you want to solve so in
that business problem you to solve you
you have to take care of several things
out there the first is the cost of wrong
predictions so I'll tell you a very
basic we we'll have a basic example so
let's take an example what we want to do
we want to predict we we want to Pro we
want to forecast you know we want to
forecast our retails for example what
happens in a company that sometimes
because of the wrong estim
sometimes what happens there might be
Overstock of a particular product which
leads to wastage of resources and they
underst stock which leads to again a
revenue loss so in both cases underst
stock or overstock of your um of your
res of of your products is being the
problem in a retail company so you not
to you you want to really solve that so
the first one is what is the cost of
wrong predictions if we actually if if
our model gives if we actually don't
estimate the right thing the cost of
wrong prediction is quite High Overstock
means having more stock of your products
leads to wasted resources and possible
rofs for unsold products and understock
which means which is Miss sales
opportunity and unsatisfied customers
because they're not able to get the
things on time and both of them has the
quite high pro quite High U costs
because one at one point you if you
Overstock wastage resources and one
point it is like misses opportuni so we
we have to worry about and if we solve
this problem we'll fix Overstock and
understock
problems so let's break down the process
of sale forecasting processes so
basically in this sale for forecasting
process you decompose the process of
sale for forecasting into component task
see see see just notice that we haven't
reached to our ml thing right away we
first of all talking about the problem
which you want to solve right and then
dividing the problem then right so now
is a sales forecasting problem you're
dividing the problem into several things
first is data Gathering second
historical sales analysis market rint
analysis and actual forecasting so what
does data Gathering mean getting the
required amount of data which we need
analysis of the past right what is the
trend of the market and the last one is
actual
forecasting so what you do you you
actually data Gathering is something
which is pretty easy right not pretty
easy I would say it is it is it is
something which so let's worry about
what things can be solved in ml in this
case and also will will it return High
Roi right High return of our time right
which we devote in this so of course we
can have data Gathering has all the
equal importance but what eventually we
could solve for using ml is this actual
forecasting to actually estimate what
will be the number of pro stocks which
which we should have in a certain time
period and we can actually use this IML
in this actual forecasting task where it
could analyze the past sales data and
market trends right to predict future
sales with higher accuracy than whatever
traditional methods they're using so now
you might have noticed that now after
dividing it it into the components we
understand actual forecasting is the one
which we should solve for by by
utilizing the past data and the market
trends and the ROI could be estimated by
potential increase and a decrease in
sales wastage due to improve forecast
for example if your for forecasting is
good you will be actually noticing that
you're that there's a decrease in a
wasted resources which means eventually
it's helping right and then what you do
you actually worry about what what will
the cost of developing and P maintain
the solution so if your wasted resources
are decreasing a lot so you might focus
on building this AML solution of
it and then you have to prioritize it in
this case you or to prioritize the
implementation which is the actual
forecasting in this
case Okay cool so we'll talk about
structuring in our project as of now I'm
just leaving the slide so there's a
machine learning canvas which usually
you have to really worry about while
building a project or solving a business
problem using machine
learning the first one is value
proposition right so first of all we
have to define the value proposition
position what is this importance Define
the problem the importance of the
problem and what who will be our end
user right so basically you want to for
you you need to understand for who we
need a product service this product will
be benefiting jofre M value proposition
positioning statement which means for
Target customer who need our product/
service is a product category category
that benefits basically we have to make
sure we have to make sure the problem
importance is so high right to proceed
with the solving for the problem another
one is we have data sources from where
we should identify potential data
sources and it can be including some
internal databases or apis or open data
sets and Etc which comes into that place
we should also consider hidden costs
such as data storage purchasing external
data and Etc which comes into that place
so basically this is the second second
step third step is what will be the
production task whether it is a
supervised or unsupervised problem or
aom detection classification regression
or ranking problem you just worry about
what will be my input what will be my
output what will be the degree of model
complexity right this will give you more
clear clear Clarity before building the
before going in actual cing part then
next step is feature engineering so
basically you have to interact with a do
experts for example you might be working
you you might building something a
really good in in healthcare space but
you're not a MBS doctor right you
actually need to have the MB doctor to
actually get more information to
understand the terminologies and
actually make more information extract
more information from the available data
sources which we get that's where
feature engineering comes into comes
into this place offline evaluation which
means you set up some Matrix to evaluate
your system before pushing it to to the
deployment pre-employment means using
the model by your own and understanding
the prediction errors and what will the
cost of wrong
predictions and then using predictions
to make decisions how will the end user
interact with a interact with the
predictions will it will it involve any
hidden cost which can be in human
intervention and lot of things which
comes to that
place and at last we collect the new
data we keep on col collecting new data
for model retraining and preventing
model decaying performance we also
consider cost for data collection and
the role of human intervention in data
labeling because it's very very
important for having good labelers in
the data to actually for for actually
helping models to extract patterns from
it and then you have deciding frequency
of model retraining and Associated
hidden cost for for how many time we'll
retrain a model at what interval and as
well as if there's any changes in a tech
tag which you have to worry
about and then what you do you set up
Matrix to track system you to monitor
your model once your model is deployed
you know you have to deploy it so that
so that for example in spam deduction
you have to you have to keep on check
you have to have some Matrix to keep on
check whether your model is giving the
wrong predictions or not that's the
monitoring part and also identify
situations where AIML may not be the
best solution it can be some subtasks of
it where you actually worry about
something outside of IML right because
it's very very important to understand
if we can solve it without IML because
it's very um hard as well as the the
cost of implementing am solution is
pretty much
big and also so so that's that's pretty
much about um what exactly we need to
worry about uh in whole mlops procedure
so there are three things which comes
into into the workflow of building uh
workflow building the machine learning
based software development that there
are three main artifacts in building
ml-based software the first one is data
second one is machine learning model and
third one is code and three main phases
which which is engineering data
engineering ml model engineering and
code engineering so let's talk about
each step by step so data engineering is
like you have to collect the data
acquired the data and prepared the data
accordingly right what is uh and then
also make sure that there are certain
things which is which we have to make
sure in this so the pipeline of data
engineering here how goes pipeline means
stepbystep procedure to go ahead right
first of all you ingest the data and the
data which was ingested you explore and
validate the data that is coming from a
true space as well as explore it to
understand the data you format and clean
the data you label the data if it is a
supervised learning problem and you
divide the data into training validation
test set so so that that can be used for
training the models I'm assuming that
you already know about training and
validation and all those things which is
already there I'm not over here to
explain you ml things I'm over here to
explain you things which really
matters so the next step is model
engineering so the core of ml workflow
is writing and executing ml algorithms
the pipeline here it like this you train
the model you evaluate the model
validate the model which predeployment
so that makes that your model is working
pretty well you test the model right
using the unknown unseen data set which
is the Unseen um samples which your
model has never seen and then you
package the model so that business can
be used accordingly it can be pkl file
or any such you know uh models and at
last but not the least you have you
deploy the model you serve the model in
a production environment you monitor so
that it's it's it's going well and then
you record and then also log it so that
for every INF for for every prediction
it is making so that we can go back if
there's anything goes
wrong so I hope that you understand
these three things pipelines we'll go
into that greater detail when we
actually do this project we'll implement
it live over there so that you could see
pretty much
easily and we'll use zml to develop
execute and manage our machine Learning
Systems so I'll talk about uh pipelines
and steps in pretty much small detail
and we'll eventually go to projects
because I think that is pretty long varo
so we'll just try to talk in Greater
detail later on as of now let's talk
about what are
pipelines so zml follows a pipeline
based approach so don't worry about the
zml thing as of now we'll come to that
what exactly it is data on but currently
let's talk about pipelines and steps so
zml follows a pipeline based approach to
organize machine learning workflows it
can be methods to promote efficiency rep
repetitively sorry repetitively and
collaboration in your projects so SA for
example uh so what is pipeline it's like
a movie production process a pipeline is
a high level workflow that organize a
series of tasks to create a final
product in the context of a movie
production process it can be of script
writing casting filming editing and
distribution casting depends on stre
script writing filming depends on
casting editing depends on filming and
distribution depends on editing
everything is interrelated everything is
step by step not you you you can't do
scripting and then editing right so
similarly in zml your pipeline
represents a complete ml workflow and
each step over there it can be involved
a step can be dat a preparation feature
another step feature enging so feature
enging can only be done if the if the
previous step is completed and then
train the model to evaluate and deploy
it so here's a very basic basic example
over here so basically you you you
actually first of all uh step one which
is the prepare the you have some ml you
load the data which is using the step
decorator you have another function
which using the step decorator you train
the model you evaluate the model which
is editing and then you deploy the model
which is distribution now you combine
all these steps into a pipeline right
you have the data you give the input
data which is using a pipeline decorator
you give it to the feature engineering
and then you give the features to the
model and then you give the models to
the for the evaluation to evaluate and
then you deploy the model and then you
run this whole pipeline so it's run step
by step to reach and give you the
trained model so there are a lot of
things lot of benefits of it which we'll
discuss throughout the course right so
in the next set of lectures I'll make
sure to introduce you to bit of bit of
collab notebooks to make sure that
you're aware about basic functionality
of Zen so that we could actually use
this in our project and then we'll be go
in building our first project of mlops
so let's get started uh with this uh our
first mlops
proy hey everyone welcome back to the
new video on mlops course so basically
today what I want to do is I want to
make you familiar with core and the
fundamentals of zenel because it's very
very important to understand what are
the co Core Concepts of ZL to actually
start on building several projects using
zml zml is an open source library for
building uh full stack amops
applications and the reason why I want
to use this ziml because I personally
worked over there for for about six to
7even months over there and I've worked
there with their core team and actually
this is super simple to use that's why I
want to use ziml you can use several
other orchestrators which are available
in the market however the most easiest
one with the best ones uh is ziml so
that's why I want to use ziml however uh
you might face sever other problems U
but there's always a community which
where you can interact and uh resolve
your doubts so let's get started with ML
pipelines with zml and today uh this is
The cocol laab Notebook from Zen byes
which zml Zen ml team has already built
for us and over there this the the the
Zen pites what they want to do from the
these kind of collabs they want to teach
you the Core Concepts so I want to
utilize these and then uh record a
videos on top of it to actually make you
understand some of the Core Concepts of
zml so let's get started um and also
we'll be doing projects don't worry this
is just for core understanding because
as we say the core is the power so let's
get started uh with this notebook so uh
first of all what what we will do we
will install the zml server which is the
zml server which is very important for
us to install U you can this is a
command line uh command which you have
to paste on a terminal if you're using
vs code however you can just get started
with collab will when when we'll go to
projects you can actually see the way
I'm doing over there we we'll we'll also
make use of pyit learn because I want to
show you the demo that's why I want to
train a very simple model over here and
pipe Haring which is important for
collab and then we do it for simple
things which needed however I have
already did it so you don't need to uh
you you only need to do I don't need to
do because it takes bit of time to
download so so uh and the next uh you
need NG do account if you want to see
the visualizations and all the stuff
which is pretty easy you only need NG do
account for colab you don't need NG do
account for something if you're doing uh
for on vs code or simple python code
you'll be easily having access to that
however for collab you need NG do you
can actually have it I have a coupon
code over here it will I you can
actually I will hide it I'm so sorry for
that I'll hide it or you can just have
your own ngok token as well cool so uh
and over here you this is just for
collab setup this is not for uh any
things you which you have to learn so uh
what what we will do is uh will you you
might be familiar as it says that you
might be familiar with pyit learn
pytorch or tens oflow so as I say the ml
pipeline is simply an extension which
includes the step by step as I as I told
the example of a what I told the example
of a movie production process so and and
in that movie production you have
scripting casting editing and all those
things those are steps which are
interconnected with each other right so
the the the reason why we use pipelines
is because of the following reasons the
first one is we can easily rerun all our
work not just the model right so
basically you run each and everything
from the starting so which which helps
to uh eliminate any bucks also make our
models easier to reproduce second one is
that for every pipeline you run you have
for for for every time you run you have
the you have you can easily track the
previous previous run in this in these
kind of pipelines for example you run
the code one time and then you run the
second times and usually you don't have
the access to the previous run so
basically using pipelines you can have
the access to every runs and it can be
tracked as well and then you can comp
then you can use for several purpose for
for example comparing two different
versions of the models right and also if
the entire pipeline is coded up we can
automate many operational tasks like
retraining redeployment and all all
those things which is needed via cicd
workflows we uh don't worry about if you
didn't understood this line when we'll
actually do one simple uh project one
simple project you will see if any
things changes on the data how we how
actually pipeline help us to um this
redeploy or retrain our
model Okay cool so let's get started
with the zml so first of all you need to
have the you need to have the Zen
Library installed first of all what
we'll do we'll remove any existing files
of there and then initialize a ziml
repository which is very important uh
which is very important which is the
first step whenever you use ziml Library
so it initializes your zml in uh in your
current directory So currently you can
just use ZL in to initialize it and this
happens this uh exclamation mark shows
that we are dealing with terminal
commands so now so now I'll show you
what we exactly do for basically I'm
going to train I I want to train uh
class psychic learn SBC which is a
support Vector machine support vector
classifier on want a train a support
Vector machine classifier to classify
images of handwritten digits so
basically we we will do the handwritten
digit recognition using uh support
Vector machine so over there we have
there there is there are several images
and each image is either 0 1 2 3 4 all
the way around to the 10 so basically
you want to classify the numbers the
images handwritten the digits based on 0
to 10 uh numbers so let's get started
with it uh if you are not sure about
what is handwritten digit recognition
for should take a look at online what is
the problem is about so basically what
what we will do we we load the model we
will train the model we'll trest the
model on the and then we'll see the
accuracy however this is not the right
thing to do okay this is just for
practicing this this can be thousand X
more complex than this is very basic
version of anything right this is just a
dummy dummy thing just to Showcase you
so basically you load the digits so load
digits will load the data set from SK
learn data set so basically we'll use
the SK learn data sets to load the
digits and then what we will do uh and
then we'll reshape it so that we'll just
do the little bit of processing and once
the processing is done we'll divide our
data sets into XT train X test y train
and Y test the reason why we divide it
because so that we can train our model
on X train and Y train and then we can
test our model on testing however again
I'll say that machine learning algorithm
coding is thousand sex much more better
than this we teach in our code machine
learning course uh which is if if you
actually see the code machine Lear
course you'll see what is this so yeah
this is just for dumb example don't take
inspiration from machine learning uh
algorithm over here right and then you
simply train toest split and then you
have the support vector classifier and
then you fit the model and then you
evaluate the model okay pretty simple
now what now this is I and then you run
it you get the test accuracy now how can
we run this into how can we divide this
into experim into pipelines so what we
will do as we have the Z ziml init which
is a ziml repository we'll create our
first pipeline the first pipeline will
have the following components in that it
will import it will train it will
evaluate the model okay so are three
distinct steps in this example loading
of the data training of the model and
evaluating the model right you can
simply use we can will will we will
simply make different different
functions for different different
components over here so first of all
we'll make you'll make use of adate Step
operator which you can simply import
from zml and then what you'll have to do
you the the Importer importer Does this
does not takes anything this returns
right this is called type set the the
thing which we have to return over here
so the so basically the utter will load
the digit will reshape it will uh train
to split and then return xtrain xest y
TR by test the reason why we have to
actually write over there what is
actually returning is for several
reasons which happens behind ziml behind
the scenes because this ASV trainer
should know what type of input it is
coming to me because as we trainer will
get X train and Y train right so they
should know what type of soda to verify
the type of the data types which
importer is sending and SVC is getting
we need to actually state that this is
something which is it is going to return
this is also helpful in readability also
it happens it also helps in the back end
of the
system which is annotated and then np.
and array this is the Xtreme will return
the extem the type of that is nump array
exess type of that is an so this is a
formal annotated which will annotate our
outputs right and then you have another
step which is SBC trainer right we which
we again decorated with at theate step
and then it returns as we see over it
takes X train which we say that it is a
nump array y train it is also a numpy
array and it Returns the classifier it
Returns the classifier right so
basically it Returns the classifier
which means that we train the model and
it Returns the classifier so basically
you you can import classifier
mixing from skarn base which says that
this is the whatever it whatever it is
the type it will just make make the type
so it will be classifier mixing it will
be mix of classifiers you can easily
search online about classifier mixing if
it un confused about what type of data
type is this this is just the SVC
classifier data type you can also write
SVC over there by identifying the type
of this model the next step is it will
take the input as a X test and Y test
and the model and the model type would
be classified mix in and it will return
a float and also it is decorated by step
operator and then we just uh this test
accurate score it and then however there
there there can be several set of
classification measures just as of now
as we say that we are taking a baseline
now once we have the steps now we to
connect each and every steps so we'll
use the zml pipeline and the pipeline
will have following like this first of
all you exrain xess and you import you
use the Importer which you built over
there and then you use the SVC trainer
and then and then you use the SVC
trainer where you give the the this step
which X train and Y train you give it
and then you evaluate up so once you run
it once you run it you will be getting
and then you simply use digits SVC and
then digits pipeline when you run it it
will initiate a new Run for the pipeline
which is currently it I have I've
already run so this is the version
number two so you can you can in the
dashboard you can visit the version
number one okay and then revisit the
accuracy over here and as well as
previous
one so um you can simply go this it says
step importer has started step importer
has finished in 2.73 to2 seconds SVC
trainer has started as we see trainer
has finished evaluator has started it is
finished and then every run digits has
finished you can visualize your pipeline
runs in simply zml dashboard right and
then you can run this code and then go
to this U URL so basically when you run
it you will be prompted to URL something
like this and then you can easily go
over there and then you will Simply
Having your pipeline so basically your
password should be default okay so
basically whenever you um go over there
so let me show it to you so basically um
let me run it quickly if you want it
uh I'll run
it so you can see now it will train the
third version okay so sorry it will
train the second version because we have
reinitiated our the stuffs right so you
can simply go over there and then um it
will will run
it so now you see it's starting the zml
server you can easily go over here and
then it will it will open the zml
dashboard now once it opens you can so
basically you'll be prompted to
something like this you have to write
default over here yeah you you have to
write default over here and then click
on login so once you click on login
you'll be automatically having you'll
aut automatically go to pipelines and
then visualize your pip pipelines over
here however this is not the pipeline
which is over here you you'll be viewing
something like this so this helps you
can easily go to the previous one see
your model score come to this your model
score and etc etc so I hope you really
understood what exactly steps and
pipelines means in ziml this is just the
basic things in the next lecture in the
lecture 1.2 what what we'll do we'll I
I'll show you some of the Magics of what
zml does and then you'll be surprised to
know about that as well right so let's
get started with a new lecture
and that say pretty much simple that
we'll first of all go ahead and read
understand what our data looks like so
that it gives you much more clarity
about the problem statement which we
really want to do currently I'm not
setting this too much on business
objectives and all most probably we
focus on the technical aspects of
building this envelops project so over
here you have the data and and and the
data says the oldest customers data set
and that data set has the uh most
probably over here if you see that
customer ID customer unique customer
City customer State and then we have
geolocation data set and then we have
items data set and lot of data sets out
there so what we did we we made our
custom data set over here so if you go
and see our custom data set we have the
lot of features where we combine
everything to one and then we have the
review score which is our uh most
probably our uh review score which is
the factions scode so I'll quickly show
you um uh very basic how does it looks
like in Excel sheet because it's more
important to let you aware about the
Excel sheet because it's much more
common because currently it's bit
complicated over here if you think uh in
a basic um Visual Studio code so let's
get started with actually show
showcasing it actually takes a bit of
time because the file is a little bit
large but no worries we'll get started
with it but as soon as it as it is
opening so what I'll do what I what I'll
do I'll create several fold folders
which is very important for us which you
can take as an template for for starting
off right so let's get started actually
showcasing but before that it it
actually opened up so you see that order
ID customer ID order status order
purchase order approved that and lot of
features comes in comes into this place
and then finally you have review score
which is from 1 to five which is from 1
to five however currently we'll be not
using this review comment and we'll
delete lot of you know features though
not not because of the feature not
because of the it it does not holds
importance but or because but because
because we I don't want to make it
complex project initially you can of
course tweak it accordingly you make it
on whole data you know do do in the
setting of machine learning setting and
lot of things which which you can do
currently I want to make it pretty much
simple that's very nice so let's get
started this is our uh Target variable
and all of this is our input features
which we have to use to actually predict
our uh customer satisfaction score so
but before that what I'll do I'll
quickly make several folders which is
very important for us to get started so
um and also but but before that let's
install several libraries which are
listed in readme.md so uh one thing
which I just have to uh make a note that
you have to actually perform all the
actions all the installations every of
your operations in a virtual environment
currently I'm in customer satisfaction
virtual environment I actually use
something known as as you know what I
use I I use spy EnV you can use cond or
you can use um ven or literally any
virtual environment which you're going
to use for actually creating virtual
environment if you're not aware of what
is virtual environment it is actually
containerize all your applications into
one's environment so that your
dependency conflict does not happen I
know if you if you don't if you don't
know you might be not able to understand
this so we have linked a very nice
resources in the GitHub repository just
before this section uh which you'll see
in the GitHub repository to actually
understand what is it version
environment means but it's very very
important to in a virtual environment to
actually have it everything on the good
page cool so what I'll do I'll quickly
install so basically uh I'll I'll first
of all pip install zml server so that
you can this is for the one who actually
wants to run the whole project Let's
ignore this and let's try to install
this first of all zml so I'll I'll quick
quickly go and install
zml so you might be seeing that it is
giving some errors so what what we have
to do we have to actually add something
like this
I hope so it works if it does not we'll
have to go to ZL ser and see it okay
cool it's actually working so it will
take some time to actually download a
zml and and I'm personally downloading
over here so that you can also see that
how exact exactly these thing works and
also what I'll do I'll quickly um import
the requirements which I have it over
here uh so that you understand it much
more in a great detail so um what I'll
do I will
have it over here okay cool
so this is the requirements.txt however
you can uh this is just for show CAD
boost SL jbm we'll not be learning about
these algorithms if you want to learn
these algorithms enroll in my core
machine learning course but um but we'll
be not learning this this is just for
installation of the libraries which is
very important for us to install it
prior however you can totally choose to
ignore this we just coding step by step
so that you understand understand it
much more in Greater detail so now it
shows that it is actually installing and
I pretty much think it is installed um
yeah so it also say that that we have to
upgrade so let's just copy from here to
here and is because the reason why I
like to upgrade it because it really
shows pretty interesting and pretty
beautiful the way it downloads not not
is this white white one is actually very
colorful that's why I like that I'll
just clear it very quickly and then what
I'll do I'll go ahead and zml up so what
is zml up up does it UPS or the or
awakes the zml server so that you can
view your pipelines you can view a lot
of things out there if you simply put
zml up but before that what you see that
it is not running the reason why it is
not running that we forgot a very
interesting thing out here before that
we have to actually write ziml init
which initiates the repository over here
which means that it it initiates the
ziml repository over here so right you
could see that that a do Zen folder will
be created over here as soon as possible
as the runs is completed so let's just
wait for a few seconds and let the let
the Zen ml gets Zen ZL in it gets
completed the reason why we want to
create the repository because we want to
containerize or have all our code inside
that repository so that it can be used
for several other purposes which you'll
realize it a later on okay cool so uh
but let let that running it's it is a
first run that's why it is a bit taking
time so let's just go ahead and create
folder which is very important for us
now you see that zml is z do dozen is
created and it says that your zml fine
version does not match the server
version the version mismatch might lead
to errors or unexpected Behavior kindly
refer to blah blah blah so let's do one
thing let's simply ziml down grade so
that should definitely replicate all our
errors out there which is this warning
because it's it's you know it I'll tell
you from my personal opinion that it's
very very important I'll tell you from
my person it's very important fix up the
warnings the reason why uh I want you to
fix up the warnings because it's because
sometimes it might happen that you'll
completely get unexpected error and
you'll never realize that you were here
right so that's why I really want you to
first of all um uh make sure that you uh
satisfy all the errors so basically it
says that your Zen cine version doesn't
as server version so you can I either
downgrade or do a lot of things to
actually get it done but uh living that
it that it is let's just go ahead and
create our folder
so the folders which I'm going to create
is first of all the Zen folders created
the data folders created one thing which
we will do in a future in another
projects of this whole course is that we
we we will not use CSV data set we will
use the poster SQL and then retrieve the
data set from SQL because in real world
setting we not eventually use CSV we
actually use uh SQL databases from cloud
or somewhere like U fster SQL on local
right and then we use from there and
then we retrieve and play with that data
right so that that we'll do it later on
but most probably just let's just keep
it very simple and let's just go ahead
with data
folder cool um another folder which I
really want to have is something as
model folder model will contain all my
um for all my files which is of like
models and stuff all the all the things
which is required for training the model
or you can also name it as a source so
let's name it as a source because that's
more important right so let's name it as
a SRC and which which is which all which
all contains your data sets now what
I'll do I'll quickly create something
known as
pipelines so pipelines will contain all
our pipelines which we have which will
build saved model will contain if you if
you want to save the model um eventually
you don't need to but you know just just
for reference we created steps so steps
will contain all our components or the
tasks which needs to be done over here
and then at last you can actually have
in. Pi so let's quickly create something
know as
inite pi and then after that we'll
create there is always there's always a
requirements txt what I'll do I'll
create something known as run pipeline
so we can run our pipeline over there
run pipeline. P cool so what I'll
quickly do I will first of all um code
all the um the data things first of all
what we'll do as as I said this is not a
formal machine learning engineering
course right is the mlops course so I'll
make sure that to keep keep things very
simple very knife right right but if you
want to learn like more of the advanced
things in machine learning there's
always core machine learning course
available out there to actually help you
out the first thing which you want to do
the first thing which we want to do is
ingest the data so we'll start off with
first of all uh steps so steps in that
we'll create the file Lim ingest data.
pi and ingest data. Pi will consist of
the steps will will consist of the steps
where we will inest the data in it so
what I'll do I'll quickly import logging
out here so that we could eventually log
when when when things completed because
it's very very important to log as well
and then I'll import from import pandas
as PD and then will from zml import step
as I as as you have seen in basics of
zml that we have to actually use this
step over there then I'll create a class
of ingest era I'll create the class of
ingest era oh my God you know the the
way my keyboard is not working pretty
well and over there what I'll do I'm
actually using copilot still but um but
uh you have to also you know give the
good documentation which will write
pretty nicely so neat so let's just
quickly do it so I'll just in it and you
can actually do it like this um which is
in it and then when you run it you can
actually write the get data and then
ingesting data from the data path pd.
read CSP and then self. data path right
or what you can do you can simply give
the pcsv this direct file to this
totally matters on what you want to
give okay so then we'll create a step so
where we can use that class we can use
and then that step will consist of the
data path which will take St Str as an
input which will the string of course
and it will return the data frame right
it will return a very nice data frame
and then what I'll do I'll first of all
make a try statement I really don't
don't want to take the help of um I
really want to take take the help of
this guy uh co-pilot but if he's helping
me I can't do literally anything so what
I'll do I'll show the way to write the
documentation first of all you know what
you write you write the description
about that function so use
ingesting the data from the data path
then we'll write the arcs arcs means the
argument it is going to take the data
part which is the part to the data and
then what it returns it Returns the
Panda's data frame right this is how you
actually do the inest data and this is
what the very interesting workflow is
then we'll write in a try try and accept
a workflow which will have something
like this where we first of all in in
instantiate our class which is ingest
data which is ingest data where will
first of all ingest data which is the
data path and then we will simply say DF
ingest data. get data and then return DF
this can be easily done in a three one
line of code as well as shown by the
co-pilot but I want to make it pretty
simple as well for the beginners if
you're watching it so for accept
exception as e and then it says error
while ingesting the data and this is
what the error is so this this is this
actually helps us to uh the best
practices of coding and same goes to
over here we have to actually maintain
it nicely right um so let's just go
ahead and quickly do it uh let me just
remove it yeah so I'll just make use of
interesting data from the T data path
and then we actually instantiate the
method so this is this is this is used
that this is used as instantiating the
method uh
arcs that's it and
you can also write instantiation but if
not bits is not required eventually over
here what what what we do inting from
data path and then you simply write
nothing and then you just that's it so
this is a basic workflow which you have
to go ahead and create this step the
first thing which you have created is of
course ingest data now we can actually
use this ingest data which we will
eventually use it later on as well so
now the next step once we have ingested
the data we need to we need the next one
which is we need to clean the data so
now now what no so now what what we will
do we will we work on creating step
which we will use for cleaning of the
data okay so let's let's do quickly one
thing we'll create first of all let's
import loging which is pretty important
to do
so this is something which is of course
and then from zml import step right and
then I create a step that step will
clean the data that step will clean the
data right and it will take the data
frame I don't know what it will return
so let's skip it as this and then we'll
pass it so we want to make this step we
want to make this step right which
cleans the data The Next Step which I
want to make is the the is the one which
trains our model okay which trains our
model so first of all then I'll write
model
train. and in that what I'll do I'll
create another step I'll create another
step okay I'll create another step so
again same thing so you have to just go
ahead and import loging and uh
import logging and then import pandas as
PD and then from zml import step right
and then you just write step and then
you just go ahead and create the train
model right train model and it takes
blah blah blah and then it returns
something and then chains the model past
them okay so that's that's something
which we have to go ahead and I'll just
quickly make this like this cool my
battery is low I'm so sorry for that but
yeah first of all this is the model
train which we have to have now once the
model train is there we have the clean
data we have inest data we have trained
the model now the next step which should
be it should be evaluation it should be
evaluate the
model uh so I'll just write evaluation
do p and over there same thing which is
something again so import logging uh
from zml import step and then at
step we just just have something Define
evaluate model and then returns nothing
okay so this is something which we have
to actually have and then once the
evaluation is done we'll have you know
some know that's it so that's that's
that's the four steps which we want to
have now you might be saying that I'm
not implemented I'll implement it the
first step is always create a blueprint
right so that it runs nicely okay that's
the first step and whenever you go you
have to actually understand the first
step now what I'll do I'll create a
pipeline okay I'll create a pipeline the
pipeline would be first of all training
pipeline pipeline dot
pipe that pipeline first of all what
what it will do it will from
zml okay so we can just from
zml zml import
pipelines and then at theate pipeline so
just just let's just write at theate pip
P line and then what I'll do I will
simply go ahead and create the training
pipeline the training pipeline the
training pipeline will consist of the
following that will consist of the
following that will ingest the data that
will ingest the data cleans the model
cleans the data trains the model and
evaluates the model okay so the training
pipeline will consist of the following
so I think that something is wrong over
there so let me just quickly do it uh
just just give me a
second
okay so now what I'll do I'll create the
uh training pipeline so let's just
quickly create a simple training
pipeline our training pipeline does not
takes anything most probably it takes
the data path right it takes the data
path as an input and that's pretty much
it I guess yeah so it takes the data
part as a input it first of all we we'll
import everything over here we'll import
first of all from steps uh from steps.
ingest data I'll import the ingest data
I hope that is working so let's just
make sure that it's not following any
conversions so yeah inest
DF cool and then what I'll do I after
inje from steps
do clean data yeah so we'll just go to
clean data
import clean maybe I'm not sure what it
is so let let's let's just go okay clean
data let's import clean data and most
probably we'll have clean DF just for
make sure that we have the good naming
conventions and then after that what
I'll do I'll import from Step strain
model and then after that from evaluate
model I just make sure that evaluate
model is there cool so once we have all
of these steps what I'll do I'll quickly
do all of these things very nicely and
show it to you the pipeline so we'll
just go ahead DF is equals to ingest
data it will ingest the path it will
clean okay so most probably we'll just
have something cleaning so clean data
will take the dfz input fair enough it
returns nothing so it returns nothing so
we just have something very nicely over
here after cleaning we'll have strain
model and then after that we'll have
evaluate model I just hope so that
everything takes um DF as an input so
that it makes sense Okay cool so now
once we have this what I'll do I'll do
nothing I'll just go ahead and then run
the pipeline okay so how to run this
pipeline so we can just create something
known as run pipeline as we have created
let's just go and create the Run
pipeline as soon as possible so we'll
just go from pipelines do training
pipeline import training Pipeline and
then you just go maybe just write train
pipeline just just for make sure that we
following the naming conventions so the
train train Pipeline and then after that
I'll just
if name is equal equals to main I just
hope that it does yeah we'll just run
the pipeline so run pipeline will happen
something like this and the data
pipeline which I'll give is I'll just
copy the whole path from here and send
it out to here there are a lot of things
which you can do you can actually upload
in cloud and do stuff which we'll do it
later on the of the
course Okay cool so let's run it so are
you ready if you are then give me a
thumbs up I'll get started with it so
I'll just go ahead and clear most
probably and
then let's run it Python and pipeline
you know the when I code I actually
listen you know lot of you know what do
you say uh music but eventually I'm not
as of now so sorry for that install
pandas pip install pandas right so let's
install quickly because that's more
important okay something really happened
over there uh evaluation right
okay as I say uh
import Hondas PD that's let's go
ahead
okay it says modu object is not
callable I think most probably what's
the error is about it's about uh let let
let let me just quickly go to that error
training pipeline
pipelines okay it's actually pipelin bro
right it's actually pipeline okay cool
enough let's go
ahead Okay cool so something is giving a
really interesting error uh because of
some of the things so let's just quickly
fix it so it when so what is happening
I'll tell you why the error is happening
it says that wrong wrong type out wrong
typee for output for step clean DF why
it says that it is expecting Panda's
data frame because you have told that it
will give Panda's data frame but it is
giving none so we have to actually write
run over
here same over here uh same over here so
it is actually expecting that um you
know uh it will return something that's
why it was initiating that
it it'll give warnings just go ahead
with the
warnings okay that's pretty nice thing
which happened cool so I'll explain you
what what what just happened you can
choose to ignore um completely about all
of these stuff like what is this user
stack and orchestrator artifact store
we'll explain later on so you'll see
that the inest has started clean DF
started right clean DF has finished
evaluate model model started evaluate
model finished trade model started trade
models finished nothing goes over there
that's it now what I'll do I I I'll
showcase you this very simple dashboard
which is out here so we'll just go ahead
and go to the dashboard quickly so the
username would be default and then login
so when you log in simply go to the
pipelines for you it might be super new
so let's just go to pipelines this is
the train pipeline so let's go to the
first
one okay fair enough so inest data gives
the output which is the data frame so
that is a data frame so if you go and
and you see the this is the output and
it also shows some of the visualizations
or you know data type of it you see that
data is imported this is called the
artifacts okay the thing which is stored
uh and over here if you see for after
every step so this injest DF has
something known as what is the name of
this what is the doc string which is
like the documentation right start time
run time and all those things
and then after that what what is the
output and the artifact so artifact is
something which is returned after every
step which is stored in some local
stores it is which is stored in some
store which can be retrieved further so
you see where where it is stored it is
stored in this U uh URI so if you go
over there and you will see a very nice
output over there if you if you go to
this particular
location okay that is the and logs are
simply nothing using cas version step to
you you might be noticed what is using
cast version of it this is pretty
interesting to understand we we'll
understand it way greater detail I'll
show you a very nice example of it just
wait uh and then you have clean DF which
is again clean DF is finished evaluate
model train model so you see the ingest
data gives the and then it does not
returns anything so this is a
visualization which you can for sure see
over
here and that's pretty much it and now
we pretty much think that our uh
dashboard is working our pipeline is
running up and we are good to go go with
it right cool so one thing which I just
want to make sure that you are aware
about is something known as caching so
uh so what if I do enable cache is
equals to
true false sorry let's run it
okay um let it yeah
cool run
pipeline
now let's see this on our dashboard
pipelines the one the latest
one so um so you see the same thing
which happened over here so I'll just
quickly you
know do it and then show it to you
okay so now this is the you you could
see another version is over there which
is version number four now ingest data
started ingesting data from this ingest
data has finished but over here do you
think that something really happened
interesting using cast version of inj DF
so zenim has an amazing and super duper
amazing feature what does it mean that
it uses the cast version so if there's
nothing nothing changes in the data if
there's nothing changes in the code or
if there's nothing changes in that step
it will use the step from the previous
run and you see that how interesting
this is that see how's the level is
going on that's nothing
changes right and we eventually using
those because the caching was enabled
but but caching was disabled right so so
catching was disabled but over here I
told to enable to to actually uh
actually I sa catching isal to for that
don't do caching don't use run from the
previous version it states step inest
data has started uh ingesting data and
then in just is finished so if you make
it true if you make it true so let me
let me just make it
true let's run
it
so uh using cast version of ingest it
uses from the clean DF also not change
evaluate model it just trains the model
in matter of seconds you see how good it
is say you're training a large language
model right and this is a feature over
there you'll be super happy that your
forast version has been used sometimes
it causes error but most of the time it
works like a
charm okay that's pretty much cool uh I
hope you understood most of most of the
things from on the next session on the
next video what I'll do I'll Implement
all these steps and run it step by step
uh and afterwards I'll deploy the model
I'll deploy the model using mlflow I'll
also track I'll show you how I how we
can use ml FL experiment tracker to
actually use this and then we'll make a
very basic stream extrem lit application
to actually use this uh to actually use
a deployed model to actually make the
Press inference right we'll use the ml4
deployment and ml4 tracking a libraries
to actually integrate into zml and then
use it currently we have the blueprint
ready so that what you have learned in
this first of all you learned the way to
about write code and to structure the
code also you learned a very important
thing that it's always good to start
with preparing a blueprint and then
starting coding it I hope it really made
sense to you I'll be catching up in the
next video
bye-bye hey everyone uh welcome back to
another video so what I'm going to
achieve through the this video is we
will Implement all the steps which is
listed out here so that with the clean
data ingest data evaluation stuff
however uh we'll we'll do it in very uh
nice way I'll show you the way to write
code in a nice way by using design
patterns I hope that you have already
that you're already aware about the
design patterns before you started this
project if you are not then also we have
a very nice resources uh which which
will be linked of course before this
lectures you'll be also you'll be taught
the basics of patterns like strategy
pattern Factory pattern singl ton
pattern and all of this is already
taught to you so let's get started with
actual imp implementation of uh data
cleaning and see if you're not aware
about these patterns we actually teach
in our course cor machine learning
course you can actually consider
enrolling over there or we'll add before
this uh section as well cool so in
Source what I'll do uh we have several
other so first of all in s SRC will
Implement all these classes the classes
of these steps and then use the classes
from this in these type in these steps
first thing which which I really want to
develop is data
cleaning and data cleaning is something
which is obvious which we have to work
on so let's get started with actually uh
creating uh data cleaning classes so I'm
going to start off by importing logging
if we really need to log literally
anything and then I'll import from ABC
import ABC and abstract
method uh and then after that from
typing import Union but I'll just make
I'll just import some basic libraries
and then as we need we can import more
so I'll import pandas as well import
pandas as PD and then from escale learn.
model selection because we are going to
split out data as well so what I'll do
I'll create a abstract class abstract
class for defining a strategy for
handling data okay you might already be
aware by several animals example of
strategy pattern and all so first of all
create abstract class for defining our
strategy this is known as the data
strategy this is this will be an
abstract class this abstract class would
be abstract class
defining strategy for
handling uh data Okay cool so now this
will uh with we'll create an abstract
method in in it we'll create an abstract
method this you know the reason why we
do it is already known to you the reason
why why we do it is to just make sure
that we have a that we can just that
that data clean class will show the same
handle data right we have to make the
same class so when when when we'll work
on other the the the the strategies of
these data cleaning so you you'll see
how handy it is so handle data this will
be the data frame because I expect the
data frame uh
DF pd. datf frame and that should return
that should return um set of you know PD
data frame or the series so basically we
can we we we can just as I say
from uh from typing import
Union and then you simply add
Union and then pd. data frame and it
will return pd. cies to okay so this is
what it is going to uh return however
this is just an abstract class this is
just a blueprint I would say blueprint
mean this is what we have to implement
in our strategies we can override this
method to implement our own custom
Solutions so let's first of all start
building data pre-processing strategy so
we'll we'll build a data pre
pre-processing strategy data pre
process okay let's make it little good
strategy
and that will have something know some
something which is that will inherit
data strategy which is an abstract class
so that we can overwrite this handle
data right override this handle data so
when as soon as we have the handle data
so it will it will take the data frame
as an input and it Returns the data
frame as an
output okay so we don't need to logging
as of now so it will try so we will have
the try and exceptions try uh so
basically so basically I'll I'll first
of all drop certain you know uh um
certain columns from the data because
this is something which as as I already
told to you that we want to make it
super duper simple that's why I'll I
I'll Dro several columns however these
columns are not like they're not
important they are actually very
important just for Simplicity for this
project I'm going to delete some of the
uh some of the um uh columns from the
data because that's more important right
so what I'll do I'll just um I'll just I
have already WR the names of the The
Columns which I have to delete so I'll
just copy them out from quickly from
there
uh yeah so you can also see that order
approved that order you know received
that and all those stuff which is
required over here
okay very cool so data. drop you do you
drop certain uh columns you drop certain
colums out there and then you simply go
ahead with it okay cool so now what I'll
do I'll go to go go to the next step I
really hope that it works nicely yeah
cool so now what I'll do um there are
some certain columns there are some
certain columns which
has which has the um null values okay so
what I'll do I I'll quickly fill up the
null values you can do by two or three
two or three things okay what what you
can do you can actually uh do the when
these things are analyzed when you do
the Eda part however I have done already
Eda on my part as as as I said you can
actually make the Ed and then see which
columns and all I've already did it just
for Simplicity so that it actually makes
sense to you to actually get started
with directly with the project there are
some certain columns um which is
actually you know um there's some
certain columns which which has the null
values and we'll try to you know uh make
it work so here we go so the data which
we have they so basically these these
columns fill now with a median of that
column and in place equals to true with
the median of that column in place equal
two median means we have to take the
median of this and then we have to
permanently apply this on our data right
and there's review common message which
Al also fill the null values with no
review because there are several n null
values in the data so that we can just
write no view over
there okay that's very cool so now what
I'll do I will just go ahead and we will
we will drop the columns we'll drop the
columns which are you know uh which are
of non which are of non- number type or
some some some columns which are
actually you know um uh numbering times
okay so basically we'll just take
columns to train a model who are numbers
however you can take like see the the
reason why I'm doing this the selecting
the number is not because of I want to
you know I I'm doing it on purpose it is
like the reason why is I just want to
make this project simple so I'll select
the AL select the columns which are of
numeric so that I don't need to apply a
lot of processing steps okay so what
I'll do I will simply go ahead and data
is equals to data do select data do
select select data types I'll select the
data types which are
include uh numbers so NP do number okay
so this data will have the
columns we have the data which are of
only numeric type so now we don't need
to worry about categorical encoding
ordinary encoding or whatsoever or even
tokenizer of this this is also removed
okay but you can do lot of things out
here you don't need to remove this you
you actually Implement another
processing strategies where you encode
the data where you tokenize this re
review comment messages and a lot of
things which you can do over here we'll
also drop a couple of
uh couple of you know uh columns and the
columns which we have to drop is the
following so the first one is is uh
customer zip pre prefix and the order
item so these are the columns which you
have to drop the reason why we have to
drop because this is not important at
all okay so we can just write data is
equal to data drop drop equals to true
and then return data accept exception as
e logging error and raas E cool so um
you might be worried about like what did
I did over here first I dropped certain
columns which is not required for us as
of now because of the because because of
making the project simple second you
drop the you actually fill up the null
values which are available in the in
these kind of columns and then you only
select the data which is a numeric type
we are not selecting the categorical
encoding just categorical data that's
just because of the Simplicity of the
project and then you drop certain
certain uh you know um uh columns and
then you just return the data that's
pretty much it that's pretty much it
you're
doing that's pretty nice so now what
I'll do I'll create another strategy the
another strategy is data split strategy
so basically
data
divide
strategy and then that will inherit the
data strategy and in that we'll just
quickly
create strategy for dividing the data
into train and testing set we'll again U
make the handle
data
and then the data it will take p. data
frame and it will return you know it
will return it will return the union of
pandas data frame and series you will
notice why I'm saying Union Union means
uh both of them so here we go so I
quickly explain you what does it matter
so X is equals this is all copilot
that's why I love him so data. drop we
are dropping the um the the the target
variable and then we have Y which is the
target variable and then xray in by xra
y Train by test and give the test size
to be 0.2 and the random state to be 42
and the next train is the panas data
frame X taste is the pan data frame y
train is a series and Y test is a series
that's why your output of the
combination of both of
them I hope it makes pretty much very
sense so now once we have that now once
we have that we will make we'll make a
final class where we will utilize where
we'll utilize both of these strategies
into that class so we'll create another
class which is data cleaning okay the
data cleaning data cleaning class which
will process the data and divide the
data so I'll just create create data
class for which will which
preprocesses okay processes the data
oops
and divides it into training and testing
set cool so what I'll do I'll quickly
create Define need and then it will take
self data frame and it will also take
what strategy you want to implement that
strategy would be the would be the data
strategy it can be either you know this
these are are the these are the types of
data strategy right this abstract class
so strategy will take either do you want
data process strategy or divide
strategy Okay cool so what I'll do I'll
quickly self.
strategy see equals to
strategy okay so now we'll we'll have
another class which is handle data sorry
method and that will that will either
return Union or you know a simple Panda
State data frame so this will return
self. strategy. handle data and then
self data so basically the strategy will
for for example if someone chooses this
data divide strategy so so so data we
can use the simple class so basically
someone can someone will go and just run
this class data cleaning
so some something like this if name is
equal equals
to is equal equal to
main
oops I'm s for
it okay um over here it will just say
data cleaning
okay so it will say something for for
example assume that we reading this uh D
CSV file however we are not going to do
it right now and then data cleaning and
then data cleaning is we'll instantiate
this with data and then we want to use
this data pre-process strategy so that
data pre-process that data cleaning will
use this data pre-process strategy in
this case over here and then it it has a
method called handle data it will run
over
there then you can same same way you can
give it another strategy right which is
data device strategy it will do nicely
okay so I hope that you really
understood the the wave that we do this
is called a strategy pattern where you
first of all create the abstract class
and there are several strategies in it
which is data pre-process and data
divide and then create the final class
which will make use of those strategies
uh over
here okay and this all this this is
actually very helpful when actually be
just for flexible code writing as well
as readable as well as not writing so
much of FNL statements
cool so what I'll do I'll quickly
implement this into um clean data so
let's implement this into clean data
that's more important for
us okay so clean data we'll take the
data frame as an input and then we'll
just uh go ahead and
try and then let's go so first of all
we'll import we'll import what we we
we'll have to import uh
from source. data cleaning
I'll import
data
cleaning data divide strategy and data
pre-process
strategy
Okay cool so once once we import this
now we'll just go ahead and use it try
and then try and accept so basically
first of all we'll we'll create a
processes process strategy so over here
we can just go ahead and create Pro
pre-process process strategy process
strategy and then we C the DAT data
cleaning
class data cleaning is equals to data in
instantiate the data clean class by
giving this process strategy and then we
will uh have something which is
processed data is equals to the the
object which we have object which is
data cleaning do process data okay
process data sorry sorry sorry handle
data so what is that eventually doing we
have this class we are giving the
strategy which we want to use we want we
want to use the data preer strategy and
then we are calling that strategies uh
method which is handle data which will
handle the data then we'll have the data
divide
strategy or maybe divide strategy right
and then it will again data cleaning and
then you have something known as process
ESS data in this case not the data now
you have the device strategy now we can
simply make use of XT train YX test y
train y test do handle data because it
is returning Panda's data frame in
series and then we have to actually
loging data completed and then excepts
except as e loging error raise e okay so
now one thing which is missing is it
returning none it's returning xtrain X
test y train and Y test right so we'll
use something known as annotated which
is the python built-in type setting path
parameters a type hend parameters so
let's first of all quickly do this from
typing extensions from
typing extensions I'll import annotated
which is a formal one so annotated what
it will do and also we we'll have to
import the tupo let's quickly import tle
from
typing import tle
sorry uh over here we'll have two p and
then
okay so annotated the first output the
first output is of course pd. data frame
and then it will it it's actually xtrain
right it's actually xra now we have
another one which is annotated X test
and then another one y train and Y test
and mostly we are done so so basically
this is what happens that we are done
and now one can actually now it says
that it will return the tle it will it
it will return the following it will
return the four four types which is data
Frame data frame series and series which
is an annotated using annotated uh from
typing EXT extensions so I hope that it
makes sense uh now I let me see what
type of error it is giving it's mostly
because of the this I hope this fixes it
so now we are done with this step now we
can just you know simple make it very
basic doc string cleans the data and
divides Orcs so let's just write
Orcs
raw data and then simply you just have
this you can also write
returns training data testing data
training labels and testing labels okay
so now we have this class ready for us
and then we can actually use sorry step
ready for us where we using several
strategies and then we'll actually
implement it okay so I hope this this
actually makes sense to you all now the
next thing which which we'll work on is
something something known as um which is
something known as model development so
model development is something which is
pretty much important we'll actually
make use of uh linear regression which
we will Implement right away from here
Implement right away from here and you
know so yeah um so we'll just Implement
linear regression out here so that it
makes sense for you to get started with
it so we'll Implement a basic LR so that
it is not however there's a lot of
things which you can Implement I in the
representative which you'll get you'll
be having implemented these kind of like
you know random forest or XG boost CAD
boost and then after that we'll evaluate
our model So currently we're not
focusing on core machine learning kind
of thing we're just focusing on building
a full mlops project so I can build it
in more complex situations another waye
which we have is evaluation as well as
where we'll we'll we'll make an EV
evaluation measures and then after that
we'll also make the steps for it and
then we are mostly done however there's
something which is left left which is
something know as deployment pipeline
we'll also deploy the pipeline right you
will be amazed to see the the way we
deploy the pipeline the way we run it
right and the way we run it and also
we'll just use a stream application to
actually go ahead with this then
deployment so I hope that really it
makes sense so let's catch up in the
next video so now everyone what I'll do
I'll go to the next step which is model
development which is pretty much
important as well um so let's get
started with model development quickly
and then try try try to complete this
project as soon as possible so modal
depth. pi and in that what I'll do I'll
create a I'll create again the you know
uh abstract class and then we have to
extend that abstract class from
ABC from ABC import ABC and Abstract
method so let let's just go and start
off with it so we create a class model
the class model will have ABC right this
is the abstract class for all models
this is abstract
class for all
models um and then after that we'll
create an abstract method the abstract
method and Abstract method will be
called as a self train and that self
train will have something as X train
which is train training data by train
which is testing sorry uh training
labels we we can also create some method
known as optimize uh but it's not
required as of now so let's just leave
it so uh I'll create a very simple class
see my point again I'll say I'm
emphasizing on it first of all focus on
learning about amops and then
implementing complex models and stuff so
I'll just make a simple linear
regression model on top of it so let's
just make a simple linear regression
model and then it will take xtrain and
by train and
quirks it will uh first of all for
together and it would just Okay cool so
we'll have some some something which is
training and the training we'll first of
all we'll just import from SK
learn do linear model import linear
regression and uh most probably let's
name it as a model okay it makes much
more sense okay so um I'll just make it
over here quickly which is reg equals to
linear
regression
qux and then reg. fit which is and then
return the regression and then return
the regression right if we can also put
put this in a try and try an error so so
try accept Okay
cool okay that's very nice so now what
I'll do uh so now what I'll do I'll
simply go ahead and uh you know just we
have the model training model ready
however uh we'll see in the next Pro
which we do this is model development is
much more complex because we have to
first of all train the model validate
the Assumption test if things are
working or not you know tweak the data
fure engineering cleaning which we'll do
in the next project don't need to worry
about it okay so this is the model
development which is linear regression
model where we simply fit it and then we
train the model we complete the training
of the
model so let's quickly go to model train
and then we just Implement something
over here so uh what I'll do I'll just
go ahead and then import from model
sorry from
Source model def UT linear regression
model right yeah L linear regression
model now what I'll
do I'll simply go ahead and
uh I'll simply go ahead and then first
of all we have to first of all get the
get the data which we have to so it will
take several input so it will take extr
X test y train and Y test so let's just
take cell extr
and then Peter data frame X test y train
okay X
test white train and white test and it
will uh yeah that's pretty much it it
will return regression mixing so
actually it will return the linear
regression model right however there is
something known as regress and mixing
right so from SK learn from SK learn do
base okay
base import regression
mixing regression mixing is a type of
you know which is the type like of
course we are going to um output the
regression algorithm right trains the
model and then simply you know
appreciates the model my uh I mean just
stain the model that's that's pretty
much
a Okay cool so let's just first of all
do it and then let's go on the next PATH
so the model which we have is equals to
none and we'll also make a config do PI
we make that
config.py so make some something as
config.py and that config.py will have
from zml do steps
import base
parameter base parameters and then
create something as model name config
that will have base parameters out here
and it will contain the model
configurations which we which we want to
add model configs which which can be
model name first of all model what what
model name which we want to use what
model we want to use and then yeah so so
that's it so that is the model name
which we want to use so first of all
we'll import some something which is
over here we'll import a model train and
then we'll import um
from do config
import model name config and it will
also take config which will be the type
of model name
config okay Okay cool so now it will it
will also take the config so config will
contain the stuff so if so
if if the config do model name is linear
regression we will say um just just you
know use that model which is linear
regression model linear regression model
and then just train the model on X train
and Y train okay that that is something
which you really want to do or what or
what what we can do we can just have
have something which is U
model so it will of course it it should
it should return something right so let
me just go and quickly see yeah it is
returning lineation model we just have
train
model is equals to model train and X
train X test and it Returns the train
model
else uh we can just write you know
something which is model name not listed
or something some something like that
you can raise a value
error
okay so um the reason the the reason why
why I do this over here you might
Implement other models as well you can
just go ahead and Implement class random
forest model right random forest model
so you can just go ahead and don't don't
don't need to change the name you just
say if the config says if the config do
model name says random for regressor you
train another model so this is how it
works okay you don't need to worry about
like lot of things out out here it's
very simple to understand so just have
it as an
try and accept exception as e logging
error and then raise the E Okay cool so
that's it about the training of the
models we'll just go ahead and quick
quickly create some something known as
evaluation system part so let's just go
and create the evaluation part as
well
evaluation
Pi I'll just go ahead and create the
evaluation. pi so again over here we'll
create a very basic again abstract class
and then it extend that abstract class
to other um strategies which you're
going to use over there from ABC from
ABC import big ABC and Abstract
method and then we'll just have class
evaluation that that will take
ABC and then it will have something it
is an abstract class right it's an
abstract class
defining strategy defining strategy for
evaluating our
models right and then we'll have
abstract method abstract method will
have something calculate scores so it
will calculate the scores out here which
is y true and then it will it it it is a
numai in the array so we just import
numai as NP so nump and the
array and by prediction which is also
the numpy and the array so cool so over
here you have something which is
calculus scores which is abstract method
and then abstract method will have
something over here which is y to the
the model prediction sorry ground thr
and the model prediction now what I'll
do I'll simply go ahead and uh create
several strategies for it the first
strategy which I which I'll create
something as MSE so that that MSE will
inherit the abstract class of evaluation
and this is this is the evaluation
strategy this is the
evaluation this is the evaluation
strategy that uses mean
squ eror right mean squ eror and then
we'll create the calculate score that
calculate scores will take self again y
y true and Y
true and which is of of course num and
I'll just copy it from
here
Okay cool so uh again so we'll just
start
with we'll just say we have
entered calculating msse so it will
start off with the calculating MSE so
basically we can use simply something
known as from Cy learn Matrix from SK
learn. Matrix I'll import mean squ error
and R2 score so we'll just go ahead and
then just do it so let's let's do so
we'll just have some something MS e
we'll just give y true and Y PR we just
say that it is done and then we return
the MSE otherwise we see if there's
anything wrong which is error in
calculating scores and that's pretty
much it so uh it Returns the MSE so now
we have one strategy done we'll go and
create another strategy we'll go and
create another strategy another strategy
would be R2 score so R2 score we'll have
the evaluation strategy that you that
uses so that that uses R2 score and then
we'll just calculate the scores and then
give everything out so it just
implements automatically of course you
can add your documentation on your own
over here I'm I'm not adding it right
now please add it by your own the way I
have taught you to do so we'll have
we'll have another um evaluation
strategy which is evaluation rmsse and
then over there we'll again that's
evaluation strategy that uses the root
mean squared error to calculate stuff so
it just again just you know mean square
error and then rmse and squared equals
to false so basically over here your
calculating the root mean square error
right okay so now we have the rmsc also
done so we have several evaluation
strategies totally done now we'll just
go ahead and then implement it in
evaluation out here so now which is the
last thing which you have to do is very
very simple that you actually implement
this so we have uh so first of all I'll
import
from SRC do model Dev sorry
evaluation I'll import msse
rmsc and
R2
R2 is it
there evaluation R2 yeah R2 is there
cool R2 is there um so it will just
first of all we'll have the evaluate
model this will take lot of things first
of all it will take model okay that
model would be a regressor mixing so
we'll have to UT this is the type of the
model would be the regression mixing
because it is a regession regression
model right so import regressor
mixing then we'll uh then we'll uh get
the X test then we'll get the X test
that X test will be the Panda's data
frame and then we'll get the Y test
again for and for understanding now
let's try try to implement the solution
let's try to quickly implement the
solution so first of all we'll get the
prediction we'll get the prediction
quickly the prediction which we'll get
is model do
predict and then on the X test so model
predicts on X test we we create MSE
which is is equals to MSE class so so
sorry
MSE class is equals to
MSE and we use that MSE is equals to MSE
class class. calculate scores it will
simply just have to give y test and
predictions and then we are done so now
we have another ver is R2 class R2 class
and then about and and then after that
you have calculate the scores and that's
pretty much it and then you have another
rmsc class R calculator course and then
that's pretty much it cool so we'll
return at least let's return two things
let's return um msse let's let's return
R2
score and rmsse right because that's
more efficient to actually look at the
Matrix so we are done and we can just
put this into
try and then this into accept eror
evaluating the
models Okay cool so now we are mostly
done the one thing which is left out
here so you might be thinking what is
left guess what is left so over here we
are returning to R2 score and RMS so we
also have to indicate over here that
what thing we are returning so I'll just
import
from typing import Tuple and from typing
extensions I'll import
annotated okay so this will have two and
then it will return two things let's
annotate the float R2 score as as the
RMS okay so now I hope that it makes
little bit more sense now uh I really
hope so yeah cool so now we have the
evaluate model also done which is which
means that we are pretty much done with
ingesting of the data cleaning the
data training the model evaluating the
model now you understand everything is
completed now what is left let's worry
about that so we have something known as
run pipeline so let's try to go ahead
into into that Pipeline and let's try to
create the pipeline let's try to run
that pipeline right away from here so
let let me just quickly go and run the
pipeline um so I'll just go
[Music]
to um
yeah cool so I'll enable the cash as are
true and this takes the data path that's
that's good that's good takes the data
path we have then clean what does clean
DF takes clean DF takes something and
what what is it returns this returns X
TR XTR and by TR okay so let's just
quickly write this xra X test and Y TR y
test it it's a clean DF right this takes
the data so now it is done we have train
model so train model what does it does
train model you know takes X train X
test y train y test and the configs as
well so what what we have to do over
here we have to
actually
um
okay so let's try to uh quick quickly do
that as well um so I'll just go ahead
and uh model train so this is train
model okay so train
model and then after that model is
equals to train model
train model X test y test all the the Y
test and then we simply go ahead and
msse which is
msse sorry R2 score and rmse you
evaluate the model by giving these
things X test and Y test I hope that
really is X test and Y test that's it
yeah that's true and we are mostly done
right so now we have the pipeline ready
we have everything ready now let's go
and run the whole pipeline to see the
magic I'm pretty I'm pretty much sure
that it it will give some sort of error
but always be be on a positive side so
let let's just quickly go and run the
pipeline okay so no module named psyit
lar so let let's just quickly go and so
I'll just go escale learn pep
install and then just go and uh
okay I'll use this one because this is
much more easy to install
okay let's just wait for this to be
installed because I'm I'm actually using
the new environment that's why please
activate your environment before working
on the project please that's the request
for you all of you out
here let's wait and let's see the magic
what
happens it's running on so just wait for
a few
seconds um and after that we are mostly
done done with the pipeline of melops
you will see the dashboard the next
thing which is left which is integration
of tracking of our experiments which is
using MLF flow and then deployment of
our model using MLF flow deployment
these two things are left and then we
are mostly done with the project and
you'll be seeing like now now I really
hope that you are seeing the way we do
the project the way you know we do the
caching stuff the way we write the code
that is much more visible in the next
set of projects you'll see much more
challenging code much more challenging
topics which eventually you will learn
by
yourself so I don't know why it is not a
running but okay so cannot unpack a non
iterable step R effect object so I guess
something really have an interesting out
here so let let's just quickly go and
see what the error it has given so this
expects the data frame and this returns
X test and Y train and Y test and then
clean DF we have the
following full name uh okay my
test so let's see now if it is actually
returning oh yeah so you see that that
it is not returning anything we have to
actually return it right that's why it
is saying that that's it is returning
none and when it is asking for the
output so that's why it is not able to
cool so inest it is started clean data
completed and then we just go ahead and
then it justes does something small
training completed something failed in
the pipeline and R2 score is not
defined so let's go and quickly do it so
uh let's go to evaluation and then this
is R2 not R2 score so let's just go and
do that as
well so now you'll see how quickly it
will be run first of all it will use the
cast version you know it it it will use
the cast version of it and it will just
do the evaluate model and then you're
done you see the magic you see you you
just see the magic just simply install P
install P Arrow to remove this error so
let's just quickly go in zml up so let's
just go in zml
up please do
it it will open
it okay okay sir I'll give you the
default let's go to pipelines let's go
to train pipeline let's go to this
pipeline you see it ingests the data it
againsts the output clean the data at
the clean DF it returns these these goes
into training the model it returns these
gexas goes in evaluation of the model it
return R2 score and rmsc you see how
magical this is right how magical and
how really interesting these things has
become right now I I I really think that
this is the power this the future of ml
right if you don't know about this you
don't know anything right so I just go I
just hope that you understand it much
more greater detail we are most done
with the project however there's two
things which is left which is deployment
as as well as we are also left with
tracking of our experiments so I hope
this makes sense I'll be catching up in
the next lecture
bye so hey everyone uh let's come back
to our project so basically the project
is left with two things the first thing
which is left which is of course our
most favorite experiment Draco and the
second thing which is left was the
deployment of our model so I'll talk
about what this experiment tracker means
along with I'll talk about the
deployment pipeline so let's just first
of all talk about about what thises
experiment tracker means so when you do
the data science engineering or a real
world machine machine learning
engineering job then most probably what
you will see that whenever you have you
actually want to track every run switch
you do because you have to tweak the
parameters and then rerun it and then
check the scope from the previous one
compare it with SE several Matrix and
see how well well it was performing in
the 30th run or even in the first run
right so we need to track our every
experiments which we are doing over here
so so where should we Implement our
experiment tracker the experiment
tracker will will be implemented over
the train model so what I'll do I'll
quickly implement the experiment Tracker
out there so when you go to the model
train so model train will have something
like this and uh I'm so sorry for the
background noise I'm extremely sorry
because this is India and you keep on
hearing these voice so I'll simply
import ml flow import ml flow so once we
import the ml flow what I'll do I'll uh
simp simply go ahead and then initiate
an experiment tracker class sorry uh
object but but before that we have to
import something known as client from
zml Cent import client and that seems
like experiment
tracker is equals to client get
experiment uh get active stack so I'll
just go ahead and then do
active
stat okay wait wait for a second
yeah do active
stack do
experiment
tracker so once we have this we can EAS
easily use this so basically what what
we have to do we have to use this ml4
tracker right so we have to in in The
Decorator we have to pass the experiment
tracker and the experiment tracker which
we'll use is the following experiment
tracker do name then the name of that so
that it should be notified that this
step has the experiment track track
right so now what we have to do in this
case we have to actually you know um uh
log our models okay log our models so in
this case we have to actually use the
pyit learn Auto so basically what I'll
do I'll use mlflow dosk learn. autog
this will automatically log your models
scores and everything out there right in
the same way you have for several other
libraries so basically we'll do the m.
log same what I'll do I'll do on
something known as evaluation right so
so what what what I can do I let me just
go to evaluation part and in evaluation
part I I I have to do the same thing I
have to actually copy the two couple of
things which I did and then what I'll do
I'll simply copy the step as
well step as well and then over here
what I'll do I'll I'll simply go ahead
and then select ml slow. log matric and
then I'll log the msse right same goes
with ML flow. log Matrix I log the R2
and then I log rmsc right so I've
already logged these three things now
what I'll do it's mostly done so now we
actually can use this particular um
statement over here but but before that
let's import sorry sorry sorry sorry
let's import something known as import
flow cool so now what we have to do
guess what what we have to do we have
simply go to non run Pipeline and then
simply run the same pipeline so let's
just quickly run I've already uh done
this so let's just run the pipeline
first so once we run the pipeline it
will say that we are using the mlow
tracker and once once it says that that
we using the ml tracker it will say
something like this just no module names
ml flow so what you can do you can
simply go ahead and just just just like
zml integration install ml flow which is
simply you going go over here and then
search something thing which is like
this right and then paste it sorry for
that um simply past over here which is
zml integration install ml flow it will
take some time to install the ml flow
but before going on to running that you
have to make sure that first of I'll
explain you what the stack means stack
means that there's something the stack
which is a cont containerized thing
where your project is running and the
stack I I'll show you what the stack
contains stack contains very artifact
stores which are default okay
orchestrator which is default you don't
need to worry about what these
terminologies means so but basically the
thing which is a default the the stack
which you're working on the what do you
say stack means I'll say in terms of
environment which you're working on you
also need to stay to the ziml that I'm
going to use ml flow please register
this experiment tracker okay and just
like this as in stack you have
orchestrator orchestrator means will
will talk about it which eventually it's
called as pipeline however you have
artifacts right artifacts will talk
about all of these terminologies in very
great detail um however you don't need
to know lot more you all have so much
theor theoretical books but basically
we'll first of all install our MSO
integration once it is installed as one
as you can see over here we can simply
go and register our experiment tracker
so once you go and register our
experiment tracker you can just say
zimal expand track register ml flow
track but before that what I'll do I'll
show you what the ziml stack
list and it will show the set of stacks
which we have over here right and uh
it's taking too much time I guess
yeah okay so basically this is a very
common error which you might get if
you're using Mac so you just have to do
a couple of things the first thing we
have to do is zenal disconnect and then
what you have to do you have to run
another command which is zml up so when
you dis disconnect it so basically it is
giving another error which is error
initializing SQL store error
initializing whatsoever this is
something new error however you can
totally choose to ignore this right just
say ZL
up ZL
up okay cool something is really
interesting over here so
down so maybe down
it or we might need okay fair enough so
so then then we'll up it and if it gives
the same error we have to r on the zml
disconnect maybe and then let's see if
it works
zml
disconnect
okayl let's for wait for a few seconds
and it should
work okay cool it's working pretty fine
that's very very nice so now we have we
have fixed it so let's let's just quick
quick quickly go and let let me show you
what this set describe me so current
stack which we have as of now the
current stack which we have as of now it
will say that everything is default
right so your orchestrator is default
and artifact store is default right
orchestrator where you're running an
artifact store where your variables you
can assume the artifacts which are being
stored over there so let let's quickly
go and then also make the experiment
tracker so you can just go with the read
me and then copy this command and then
paste it which is ziml experiment
tracker register our ml flow tracker
which will have the flavor of MLF flow
so it says that unable to register
mlflow tracker which is in the same
Works Space so let's quick quickly go
and change something customer okay so
now it should work fine because I guess
I've already used it somewhere cool then
you have to just go and uh okay let's
just quickly ignore model deployer as of
now okay we'll come back to this or
let's just do one thing let's just quick
do do this as as a long because this is
important to do
so uh we will come back what does this
model deployer means and then we'll
register okay so I'll just customer and
the over here as well as
customer just copy it so that it makes
sense and it will set the deployer so it
will just set something this okay fair
enough so it says that unable to
register the stack name full stack so
again it is saying the ml stack name is
registered because I've already used it
in the past so what I'll do I'll simply
make it
customer
customer here let's just quickly do it
and then just wait for a few seconds so
most probably it's done so now you have
the ml so when you do zml stack describe
now so once you do it you most probably
see your stack over there so which is
different solve which is and now your
model deployer is mlflow customer and XM
tracker is ml tracker so we have done
this so let's now run the pipeline and
then let's see what is what what this
leads to run pipeline. pi and let's just
wait for a few seconds to to complete
the Run of it so it is initiating a new
run and it is saying something really
happens you're using unsupported version
if you cter errors blah blah blah you
just have to downgrade or something
upgrade ml flow or whatever it is giving
you can totally choose to ignore this
but there's something interesting comes
in as we see it that there's something
interesting comes in so me might need to
um maybe most probably my case say that
maybe just search it quickly because I'm
not sure what this eror
means I'm so sorry for
it what do this given no
okay
uhuh Okay so so
scorer maybe let's just go and upgrade
it what do you think so it says the
warning and let's the warning says
that try upgrading and downgrading the
scale learned version to a supported
version or try upgrading your ml
flow okay so pip install PP install
psych okay
upgrade
py
law okay it's
done and then what I can do I can just
quickly go and then serve it over
here which is pick
install
upgrade
flow okay so we might need to upgrade a
little bit version of mlflow and let's
see if this if the error is still until
processes if it processed I'll just see
the one another solution which I have in
my mind so most probably your mosts is
being fixed by you know just upgrading
reinstalling you know disconnecting then
connecting restarting your laptop fixes
the erors because sometimes you you
don't know what is happening behind the
back so you actually have to be very
careful while initiating
stuffs
please okay so that that was a very
simple letter we might have to you know
so we might have to you know upgrade
then it run completely fine okay cool
that's nice so let's let's just quick
quickly go and search default
login pipelines this
one this
one and here we go so if you go and see
the configuration you have the
experiment tracker as well you might
think two things as of now the first
thing which you which which you might be
thinking that hey a how where can I find
my um where can I find my you know uh
most probably my ex tracking URI you
know how can I view the MLF flow stuff
and and my own stuffs right so let's
I'll tell you two things okay the first
thing which I'll tell you that how you
can track the URI and stuff like how you
can view the experiments so let let's
Qui quickly go and search about uh how
you can track the URI
right so let's just quickly go
cing
so there was I'm just trying to search
one thing which was they had given a
very nice code actually you
know okay we we got it we we got it okay
so what you have to do you have to just
go quickly over there and then just go
quick quickly over there and in your run
pipeline over there and just paste
this okay just paste this because you
will get your
URI wait for a few seconds let it run we
have initiated our cach so it'll just
use the cach version of everything okay
cool so it says that your file is
available over here maybe yeah it makes
sense okay cool so um so your file is
available over there now what now what
we will do we'll just run mlflow UI
backend so something like this I'll show
you which is which you can find on
official you know ziml page as well M
URI and then you paste the URI which you
got by pasting that code which is ml
runs right let's just do
it
okay there might be some error okay
let's let's just quick quickly run it
you know it's something very important
to run I guess it will give some sort of
er I'm not exactly sure okay got an
expected argument which is maybe we have
to make it in like
this file and it last as well let let's
just see if it works in if it works then
it's
fine all right it works so let's just go
and paste it over there and expect it to
run so this is 3 3 minutes ago you just
go over there you see the Matrix which
is listed out here right you see the
parameters you see the model which is
literally logged in ml model right you
can use this model to make prediction
make ml flow to make predictions or even
pan to make predictions you see how
interesting this is this is pretty
pretty amazing this just loged each and
everything so I that's what I wanted to
Showcase to you uh I hope it makes sense
to you not what I'll do I'll just cancel
it up you can just all these commands
are available you know
get don't need to worry about
it cool so now we done with experiment
tracker in the next video we'll just go
ahead and then worry about something
known as
um deployment of our model I hope that
will also sound well to you K and catch
you in the
next hey everyone welcome back to this
video in this video what exactly I'm
going to do I'm going to actually cover
the last of the last thing which is
deployment pipeline so we'll use the ml
deployer to actually deploy our model
locally so that you can use it uh and
and make predictions right and we'll see
how to deploy a model you might have
seen that you just save the model use
some fast tape applications slow load
with job lib and then you do it that's
really not true which happens in the
production use case you actually use
something known as mlon deployment or
Seldon deployment pipelines stuff to do
it so what I'm going to do I'm going to
actually use something known as uh some
something really known as um ml4
deployment which is entirely used for
local deployment mostly use for local
deployment for deployment on AWS or you
know GC Cloud you might have to use S
code because that's much more advanced
deployment software but as of now let's
just go with AML deployment software or
sorry uh Tool uh to get started with
that so the first thing which I'll do
I'll go ahead and create something known
as uh deployment pipeline okay a
deployment pipe a deployment pipeline so
let's let's just quick quickly go and uh
make a deployment pipeline so what I'll
do I'll just go ahead and then create uh
deployment
pipeline okay okay so over
here I'll just scoll it down to looks
good okay so run deployment run
deployment dop right let let's just go
there and then just first of all remove
all of this because I you know the
reason why I like to remove all of this
because I think that gives me much more
pleasure if I remove all of this because
that seems like okay fair enough you
have something uh off the load that's
why I really really like this stuff okay
cool so let's just go to run deployment
and then in run deployment what I'll do
so basically you might have already used
uh click over there right so so
basically we'll create two pipelines
we'll create two pipelines the pipeline
which we'll do so let's first of all
create the pipeline as well which is
deployment pipeline
deployment uh
pipeline Pi so in that deployment
pipeline. Pi we'll make two pipelines
which is continuous deployment pipeline
I'll explain you what this continuous
deployment pipeline means as well as
inference pipeline later we'll explain
what do it mean as of now let's just go
in quickly as of now assume that
continuous P pipeline it's like a
traditional pipeline which we have built
prior so let's just go from pipelines do
deployment pipeline we we going to
import some certain things so as of now
let let's just go with this which
is deployment Pipeline and inference
pipeline okay so
inference pipeline okay and then what
I'll do I'll simply go ahead and create
some do do one thing is I'm going to use
click okay I'm I'm going to use click so
that we can just state in a command that
okay we want to deploy or we want to
predict or whatsoever so I'll just go
ahead and then create a click command
which is click. command and click option
click option would be click option would
be uh so let me just quickly copy it
because that's something is easy ra
rather than I write whole set of thing
so let me just copy it over here okay so
click man is conf right config and then
it will say okay in config what do you
want to choose you want to choose deploy
or you want to choose predict or you
want to choose deploy
predict so let me just quickly write
over
here deploy predict and deploy and
predict okay so you can actually state
in like this python run deployment pipe
run deployment. py do SL sorry uh Das
Dash config and then you want to deploy
or predict you can simply write it over
there and then you have minimum accuracy
we'll come to come come to what this
minimum accuracy means in some time so
uh then what then what I'll do I'll
create something known as this which is
run deployment and that config is Str
Str and minimum accuracy is of course
number we we'll come to what this
minimum accuracy means uh okay so we'll
just go ahead and write float okay and
over here what I'll do if it says deploy
if it says deploy what I'll do I'll run
the deploy Pipeline and if it says
predict I'll run the inference pipeline
I'll run the inference pipeline okay um
so let's just quickly get started with
it so now now you might be thinking hey
is it done no of course not we have to
actually build this deployment pipeline
as well as the inference pipeline
explain you what this minimum accuracy
means so let's just go over there and
quickly create our deployment pipeline
right away so I'll just import import
numai as NP import pandas as PD from zml
import pipeline comma step and then from
uh let's let's quickly import all of
this from zl. config um you'll see where
where we'll use this Docker settings
Docker settings zl. config right that's
correct okay so and then what I'll do I
will just import some something which is
mlflow deployer so I I'll just copy and
paste all of this things so that it's
much more easy as of now you can just
forget it what does it mean and stuff we
we'll come back to this later on so let
me let me just quickly go and just copy
and paste it over here so we have
imported from zml con constants we'll
actually make use of all of this please
don't worry about it we we have also
imported our um Steps From the steps
which is clean data in that clean data
we have imported clean DF so let's let
let's just go and import clean DF then
you have evaluation in evaluation you
have evaluate model so let just go and
write evaluate model inest data you have
ingest DF so let's just go and import
that as well and in model train you have
train model which is already there okay
so now what now what I do I'll just
first of all so basically I want to
train the model right sorry I want to
deploy the model as well as if the model
is good in accuracy we'll deploy it okay
so let's and also we'll also create the
docker setting so Docker setting is like
what are the libraries or the tools
which we need over here so in Docker
setting the required Integrations which
is the the the required Integrations
which we
have
Integrations which is equals to uh only
mlflow right so we we have we want to
use only ml flow Library into this okay
now what I'll do I'll create something
known as I I want to actually use the
model you know I want to use the model
to
um to actually deploy the to actually
make the predictions but before that
I'll I'll create the basic pipeline
which is the continuous deployment
pipeline so I'll explain you what this
continuous deployment P pipeline means
let's just goe first of
all so
pipeline comma we have to enable cache
equals to true we want to enable the
caching and then settings is equals to
which is Docker first of all so we'll
use Docker settings right stalker
settings and then that's it that's
that's pretty much it so we'll create a
deployment pipeline so
continuous I guess the spelling is
correct
continuous
deployment Pipeline and then over there
we'll have first of all minimum accuracy
we'll come that what does minimum
accuracy means uh then then after that
um we'll have workers number of workers
which we need and then we have timeout
so timeout means how much like like what
what will the required amount of if it
is in Loop then at how at how much time
we should stop the run right so when the
time out should be there so so that's
why we have imported this default
service start which is from constant we
have imported this defa default service
start stop time time out so that we can
actually stop the pipeline if it is
taking too much okay so first of all
let's just quick quickly go in and then
just run the in justf we have actually
imported over there and then we have
xtrain so let's just quick quickly go
over uh training pipeline and in trading
pipeline let let's just import
everything out Okay cool so let's I've
imported everything which is we have the
R2 score as well right so now um so you
have the R2 score now what I'll do I'll
create um what do you say the deployment
uh the the deployment which is the
deployment decision okay so now now we
have once we have the rmsse now we have
the trained model so now what we have to
do we have to actually deploy the model
so there should be some criteria for
deploying our models what is that
criteria criteria can be if your model
is great if your model accuracy is
greater than the minimum accuracy which
which is required to deploy the model
then only deploy the model that's where
your minimum accuracy comes in place so
let let's just quickly go and create
something know as deployment trigger
okay so the deployment decision will
depend on this deployment trigger so
first of all let's create a step called
deployment decision okay so um so just
quick quickly over there so I'll create
a class and the class will have doc
sorry
deployment trigger config in that we
have the base parameters right base
parameters and then the minimum accuracy
the the minimum accuracy of it we we'll
change it don't worry we'll change it as
if I'm just adding a random number we'll
create a step and the step will say is
the Define define
deployment
trigger
trigger and that trigger first of all
the
accuracy uh which will be a float and
config and the config from where we are
using that the
config so basically we need a config
right so we need a
config deployment
trigger
and so you have it's simp so basically
what does it does let let me just write
it implements a simple model deployment
trigger that
looks at
the at the input model accuracy and
decides if it is good enough to deploy
or
not okay so this is a very basic
deployment trigger it says first of all
it will return the accuracy greater than
or equals to config do so basically so
basically we we'll make use of the
deployment out here so basically I'll
I'll tell you what is so the we'll
create a deployment decision deployment
decision and deployment decision will
contain the deployment trigger and let's
use as of now rmse rather than R2 score
so if if you don't know about R2 score
you can just go online and search about
it like space it's it's like it it it
indicates like whe whether it's a
goodness of it or not okay then then
when you actually actually use it right
so let's just go with something known as
um MSE or rmse right or maybe let maybe
let's let's go to R2 score because
that's more good okay so now we have the
deployment decision now so what it does
it takes the R2 score and then it takes
the which is the minimum accuracy which
is required minimum R2 score which is
0.992 it only deploys this particular
model if and only if if the deplo
deployment decision true how does it
evaluate first it checks that your R2
score is greater than this or not if it
is then when it deploys the model then
it will go to the next step the next
step is mlflow model deployer step so
what is mlflow model deployer step so
let's I'll I'll show you what does it
mean mlow model deployer
step which is over here so we actually
import from Zen integration M steps we
actually use this em model deployer
steps which actually is that we is
already pre-built step we can actually
use that to deploy our model so that
we'll have to give certain parameters so
what is the model what is the deployment
decision is the deployment decision
workers which we need so workers is
equals to workers timeout is equals to
timeout Okay cool so now we have the
deployment pipeline done now we can
actually use this for inference so for
for running our deployment pipeline okay
now um so now I think we are mostly done
with it right so let's just quickly go
and run our deployment continuous
deployment pipeline that's much more
good to get started off with and then
we'll come back to uh building up our
inference pipeline so let's just quickly
go to run deployment pipeline over there
and um uh yeah so let's just quickly go
over there and uh now what I'll do I
will simply this is the config which we
have right and this is the minimum
accuracy which is required for us to
deploy our model so we'll create
something something known as
mlflow model
deployer component
so this component will will be like em
deployer so let me just quickly go ahe
and then import with there and each and
every libraries which we need
technically yes so let's just import the
libraries which is required I'll just
paste it from my repository okay so
basically we'll actually use the first
one which
is ml4 deployer which is ml4 deployer
component and then this will ml4
deployer get active model deployer this
will take the active model deployer out
there and then deploy is equals to
config is equals to
deploy uh deploy or conf config isal
deploy this okay so if the deploy is
this or this it will run the deploy if
the predict is this or this it will run
the
protect cool so let me just quickly
import
my from pipelines import continuous
continuous deployment pipeline that
continuous deployment pipeline will be
the following so let's just take that
and then continuous deployment pipeline
that deployment pipeline will contain
the minimum accuracy which is required
and then after that it will have
following workers which let's may name
it as a three and time out maybe 60
seconds okay so this is our uh
continuous deployment pip plane so now
what what we can do we can actually you
know um use it so let's let's quickly
let's let me let me just copy it from
the uh repository so now we we'll have
the we'll make the predict one very soon
but but let's just write it out so we
can say that you can run your so this is
the thing which which I've copied from
um Zen M repository so it says you can
run your ml for UI it Tak the so so you
can see the visual representation of
your models right and then what it then
then what it does it Fetch and then we
have to fetch the existing services with
the same pipeline step name and model
name right so that we can say that if
there is any existing services are there
so I've just copied it from their uh own
mlflow examples repository because these
are mostly same so basically we are
fetching the existing Services if it is
running if there's an existing Services
running or not right and then we have
employ deployer step and then model
which is the model name if the existing
services are there then then we say that
the existing Services is running locally
as a Derman to stop the service it will
like this and if the service is failed
then it says the ml for service is
failed or you just say there's no ml for
prodiction server is running right so
there just use the deploy model to get
started with so this is a very basic run
deployment
um as we don't have the inference
pipeline so we don't need to worry too
much about uh so let's just quickly go
and run this pipeline up right and then
we are and then we are mostly done so
let's run this Pipeline and we have the
minimum accuracy right so we don't need
to really worry about stuff
Okay cool so let's go and run python run
deployment uh config and in that config
going to deploy the
model let's see if it gives any error if
it gives then we'll solve it right away
so it says that
materializer is not found like material
there's no module named must
materializer where in in deployment
pipeline so are we using the
materializer
I guess
yeah okay let's remove this we not using
it you don't need to worry about it just
go
ahead let's solve the error which it is
going to
give okay it says that invalid settings
can either refer to this this this
invalid setting doger settings settings
can be refer to the general settings or
stack component there there might be
some error interesting error so let
let's see first of all if where it is
giving eror okay it is giving in
deployment Pipeline and in deployment
pipeline what is it giving it's that's
that's why I say that most of our time
will go into this only just by solving
these pretty
errors
so where it is
bro okay fair enough so we actually have
to write settings to be Docker not
Docker
settings right and mostly we done okay
fair
enough okay cool let's run it
now it can be available keys are either
resources or Docker so we need to have
the docker one over there rather than
Docker settings okay fair enough so it
gives the main why it gives the main so
we have run deployment rather than main
so let's run that sorry for
that let's
wait
please
run
whoops so it says confix so basically I
there is some naming error I'm so sorry
for that again no problem you know these
things you know very silly errors which
I do you know this rectifies this I
really want a tool that rectifies us all
of this naming errors or you know import
errors and all the stuff okay it says
that wrong arguments emo deployer got an
unexpected argument called deployment
decision what is it so where does it
gets an error it gets in done deployment
and then it says okay fair enough so it
says in continuous in that continuous
you have the ml flow deployment decision
and then it says that okay fair enough
so let's let me just quick quickly go
okay so basically it's actually not
deployment
decision it's deploy decision not
deployment decision
Okay Okay cool so let's just
run
wait I hope it works diplom decision is
not defined so why did okay fair enough
again I did the big mistake it should be
over here not
there I'm so sorry for it for these
mistakes because these is this is
something you know when when things are
super occupied when you know things out
there these mistakes happens so it
initiates the new run it says missing
entry point input data path so let's
input our data path where to input the
data path okay I'll I I I'll add it over
here only because I guess that's more
important right or let's do one thing
let's write over here
data
path St Str and then let's just go over
there and then also add the data
path just copy it from directly over
here
I just quickly replace it okay I hope it
works now if it does not then we again
have to fix
something inference is still left so
stay tuned for inference and mostly
we'll be done by
then missing empty Point data path why
where it is
getting I guess okay okay okay again we
made a good error so we have to actually
put the data path to be data path sorry
sorry for
that this little little erors keeps
keeps on happening so you have to
actually debug it and see where the your
VAR code is running and stuff it is
using the cached version again I'm
saying it's like ml
deployer okay so it says that an mlflow
model with the name was not logged in
the current Pipeline and no running ml4
server was found please ensure the
pipeline includes a step with the ml4
experiment to configure that trains a
model and locks it to that so most
probably what I feel that we have to
make it false right and then let's run
it now if it does not then you know then
then we then then we'll get in a big
trouble now if it does not deploys the
model we are going to get in big trouble
if it is
not
please
let's
wait know this is something where I just
pray you know that it works out because
this is a step where you get most of the
errors and if some unknown error happens
then just you have to actually spend
your ton of time in it ton of people has
to spend your time in it you know uh
because it's not a very simple thing
actually go inside your system and see
if it works or not now see what is
happening it says no materializer is
registered for type linear regression so
default pickle materializer was used
it's not production easy so not we can
blah blah blah so basically we have to
actually make a materializer I'll show
you how to make it later
on I'm just waiting for it to deploy our
model
mlflow model deployer step and if it is
and if it goes
above service demo on is not
running okay something really happened
now so it says the fail to start the MSO
deployment service model serving ml
flow uhu okay for more information on
the status please see the logging
file
okay something really interesting happen
so basically timed out happened over
there okay let's just go and see if what
we can do in this
case so what we can do
is fail to start the
service ml flow
deployment service demon is not
running okay so zml
up
NL stack
describe is there anything which we did
wrong in the deploy we have the the
following why is giving the worst
error okay fair enough so something is
really interesting H happening over here
we actually have to run
deployment okay let's try to run it if
you see it it like
this
this might be causing some problem this
warning okay okay okay skipping model
deployment because the model quality
does not match the criteria so again it
will say the same thing so basically
what's really happening that it is not
matching the criteria so let's let's
write
0.5 this is that skipping model because
the model called does does not match the
criteria using last s deployed by step
and continuous for model so I guess
that's that wasn't like it it was not
meeting the criteria maybe that's why
yeah so let's try to I have reduced my
minimum accuracy or maybe I have not so
minimum
accuracy
0.5 let's wait now we just we can do
just one thing just wait for it and see
if it works so basically I'll tell you
what happens is in these type of cases
you have actually concentrate more you
know you have to see actually what's
going wrong what might go wrong even the
smallest thing even restarting your
laptop really works I literally seen a I
was soling an error for two days and I
saw okay fair enough like I restarted
the laptop and it works like a charm so
yeah so just just just wait for a few
seconds and let's see if it works or not
deployment trigger start ml deployment
service skipping model because the model
does not meet the criteria my goodness
so it's really interesting things that
happening out here right so uh what I'll
do I'll just quickly go over through the
code and let's see if it works and let's
see if this let let it work right and
then we'll just go and see what happens
over there okay so we have the
deployment existing
services and uh okay so it will of
course not work because this does not
Tak too much of time right so I'll just
you know go ahead and then see if it
works on your
side ml4 deployment
service and okay and then you just go
into deployment pipeline in that
deployment pipeline you
have
[Music]
the get data
for ML slow deployment service parameter
steps service demo is not working fair
enough I I I get the words the error is
about I get
it what's the error is
about step
parameters if your accuracy is greater
than then config do minimum
accuracy and your minimum accuracy is
this one
0.5 okay fair and then you have the MLF
flow model load step parameters so
basically we
have pipeline step name
running okay so let's just copy this m
deployment loader steps as
well
so what it does it helps you to get the
get all the stuff which is ml deployment
and then we have the prediction service
loader and predictor which will come to
in some details you know I've already
written this these code out actually
right so let's just go and then just you
know okay fair enough so I'll try I'll
try to run one more time maybe right so
I'll try to run one more time and then
see if it works but before that what'll
do I'll just check the everything is
working fine on that site which is run
deployment and in that run deployment
you have the
following ml flow deployment services
and then you have the to get which is
Zen model deployers MSO model deployer
do we have the Emon model deployed okay
we have the get tracking U and then okay
fair enough so I'll just run it try it
nicely again let's see if it works or
not if it does not then we actually have
to go inside and talk to zenel team and
then see if it works because you know we
have to actually have the continuous
talks to the zml you know because
because it's something you know some
something which should be which maybe
have which may be bit common in their
side and which may have they may have
solution to it or we may have to open
the GitHub issues and then may most
probably will have the error solved
because this is how we solve it it's
just we we are not expert in this we
just go to some people and then talk to
them about it right we'll try we'll try
one one more solution which is this one
we'll try do this solution which is the
L linear regression model okay fair
enough again it just just does not
matches the deployment
criteria so I want to see the R2 score
R2 score is so bad bro okay fair that's
why it was not given okay okay okay so I
guess R2 score is very bad that's why it
is not giving good errors so I'll just
add
zero maybe this this this might
run zero means like we I I want to just
showcase you that that it deploys the
model right so now I'll go and run it R2
score is zero right so of course the R2
score is greater than that so
yeah why it is zero bro something really
interesting cases happening of with me
really
interesting Okay cool
so it's weet and also we'll fix that um
which is this one we'll fix that if
these things does not Works
bet please run bro
run no materializer is registered that
that that that that that is
common deployer updating an existing
mblo deployment
service which is this
one and let's see if it this works if it
does not which is like it met the
criteria now it met the
area now let's see what it
does it should work you
know but if it does not we'll come back
and then see what it works or not
okay let's see if it works or
not updating an existing ml flow
deployment service at this this this
this stage I think it will mostly not
work because this does not takes this
much time
it will say that a demon is not working
blah blah
blah we might need to do
something we'll try one one more
solution which I have in my
mind okay service dayon is not running
uh for more information please see the
following lock file so I'll just check
it out and then come back very soon so
everyone there was a very simple error
so basically my I've already tried this
mlro on couple of environments that's
why it was like service that we have the
current service running we cannot
actually use that so what I done I
actually deleted that uh then I you if
you were working on a new the new uh you
might be working on new stuff right you
might working on new stack right so we
have to actually use the new stack
that's why it was giving me error now it
is working to totally fine the only
thing which is is not working fine is
the following so let's just go and uh
fix that thing so basically what what we
need to do we need to import something
as cast and let let me go and just
import that from typing import
cast
from typing import cast okay fair enough
so we'll just run it deploy and then
let's just see if it
works you can totally choose to ignore
the mornings and
stuff or you can just go and solve that
thing if you want so it ingested data
first after it is ingesting the data it
cleans the data data cleaning is
completed it goes to the next step which
is trains the model trains the model
then gives some sort of warnings you can
totally choose to ignore this or maybe
see if it works if model training is
completed train model has finished and
it gives some you know root squares and
then deployment trigger has started
deployment enow models step has started
it updates an existing ml development
services right it starts with the ml
development services and most latest
times right it starts the service so
let's just go in then see if it
works hopefully it should work if it
does not then I'll just you know take
his ass off okay I'm so sorry for that
okay so now your model is available you
can make the pred make your prediction
over here because it is already running
you can also delete the model if you
want so now your model is successfully
deploy it so now we need to do we need
to actually make predictions from this
model so I what I'll do I'll quickly go
ahead and then create something known as
um I'm so sorry for
it go to deployment pipeline in that
deployment pipeline first of all we have
this MSO deployment loer step which will
help us to load that model okay and then
let's go and then start doing stuffs so
uh we'll just go ahead and then create
something define prediction service
loader right so I'll just copy and paste
the code if you want but yeah but okay
it's like I already this is already
pre-written Okay so let's just go and
then write the prediction service load
out so we'll create a step where we'll
enable the caching equals to false
because sometimes caching is also not
very good then we'll create the
prediction
service service
lower and in that we'll have the
pipeline
name pipeline name name will be St Str
pipeline step name pipeline step name
will be also also St Str is it
running
boom equals to true and then model name
to be model okay and then it Returns
what it returns it returns
mlflow deployment service okay it
Returns the ml flow deployment service
so basically it gets the prediction
service started by it it gets the
prediction service over here just copy
and paste it yeah so it gets the
prediction service started by the
deployment it takes all of these
arguments in it so first of all get the
ml flow deployer stack component so
basically we'll get the mlflow
deployer stack
component so which is very simple get
active model deployer over here and then
what I'll do I'll existing fetch
existing services with the same pipeline
name and model name so what I'll do I'll
go existing Services which is mlso MSO
deployer which is MSO model deployer
component. find model server and in that
we
pip pipeline name to pipeline name pip
pipeline step name model name and
running right so if there is
running
running running to be running that's it
that's pretty much it so if not existing
Services then we say we raas the runtime
error and in that runtime error we say
that no MSO Services is
found which is like this
no step in this Pipeline and something
like this you know pipeline for the
model name is not deployed so I just
copy and paste the errors which is so
traditional errors found from you can
just just go at you know zenel examples
and then just copy and paste there it's
not a big thing then you print the
existing services or maybe it's not then
then then you return what you return you
know you return existing services so you
return the services by using so it is
actually prediction service loader it
loads the uh current prediction service
so to actually use this for model
predictions now what I'll do I'll create
the predictor so I'll create the
predictor the
predictor will have the service that
service would be the mlflow deployment
service type of that and then it then
then then it takes the NP Dot and the
array right and it returns those array
of predictions and b. ND array so what
is Arrow of array of predictions so
we'll first of will create a step over
here as well that step will be of
dynamic data importer so that will
create the step of enable
cache equals false then we'll create a
dynamic
importer that returns s Str that returns
uh string right so it downloads the data
from the first of all downloads the data
from a mock API or maybe just just just
go ahead and create data is equals to
get data for
test and it on data so we have to
actually build this quickly so let's
just go and quick quickly build this
which is
utils utils p let's go there and run it
so we'll just have import
login import andas SPD from source.
model to sorry data cleaning input data
cleaning and
data process
strategy pre-process strategy and then
we'll just use this much get data for
test where we first of all get the data
for the test and then we want the 100
one we actually clean the data we drop
the review score we convert into date
Json format that's why it is the it is
returning St Str okay now what I'll do
I'll simply go ahead and
uh make this so let's just go quick
quickly make this so I've already made
this let me just copy and paste that
because this is pretty simple to
understand okay so first of all it
starts the service um and then it loads
the data it removes some of the column
it for the columns which we want from
the data we create we convert into P
data frame we convert in list and then
we finally convert that Json list to a
nump array and then we make the
prediction from that
service
okay I hope it makes sense
now okay fair enough so let's just go
and run it
now so we mostly done now what now we
have the prediction service loader now
at last we'll create the inference
pipeline so that inference pipeline will
have okay sorry pipeline will enable the
C setting the docker then then I'll
create the inference pipeline that
inference pipeline will contain the
pipeline name which we want and the
pipeline step
name right which is Str Str so it first
of all uses the dynamic importer Dynamic
importer right and then it service which
is the production service loader it
gives the pipeline and running equals to
false let's just write running equals to
false as of now and the new prodution
production should be predictor is this
is service equals to service and then
data like this and then we mostly down
okay so we have the data over there and
then we have the service over there now
we give the service it uses that service
from the from this and then make
predictions on this data using predictor
right which is like predictor you might
have seen over here okay cool so now we
we mostly done let's just go to run
deployment and then run the pipelines so
let's just go to run deployment and then
we'll just import our inference pipeline
out there so I just go and import
inference Pipeline and once we import
the inference pipeline we'll just go
ahead and uh run our
inference pipeline so
yeah the
pipeline the pipeline names should be
continuous deployment pipeline right and
then your pipeline step name which is
mem deployer
step I guess it should work now most
probably okay so now we have done that
so let's just run the
predict it's so
tiring
please fix this error I want you all to
fix this error this is very basic you
just have to write ZL downgrade fair
enough so we get the error nice nice
nice that that is
expected
from uril import get data for
test I'm very happy that uh that you so
one thing which I'll tell you that it is
very like that you sometimes don't
understand it right because this is
something very conceptual very technical
things out there so I want you to be
very strategic in understanding stuffs
right so please be if if you're not able
to understand it that's totally all
right so it says that data process
strategy is not
there
okay pre-process strategy is not defined
what does it mean
name the pr process
strategy
mhm if it is game gives th you have to
worry about it this is something really
interesting what happened
I really hope that it does not give that
now
Yahoo okay so buil-in materializer can M
write unable to handle class numpy and
the array uh buil-in materializer can
only handle the artifacts of the
following so it gives some matter let
let's go and fix this up this is so
tiring um okay
let's go to
where built in in the predictor okay
where is predictor in
deployment it gives in
predictor andd
array
array sorry this was St Str by num so
basically the the data which you're
getting is Str Str not an
and see if it works if it is not then we
have to worry about
now uhuh
okay Json is not
defined import
Json anything else
please give me the error Fast Pro I'm
I'm I'm so worried about
errors fix this up so just say just say
it's animal down downgrade it it should
fix please yeah so we are done so now we
actually completed our stuff right so
let's just go over
here enjoy so you have the dynamic
importer prediction service load of
dynamic import outputs and then service
load output something which is a service
and then this uses output and output
output of the which is the data for test
and this for service and then uses both
of them to make the predictor and this
actually the predictor outputs the
following so if you go and see the
visualization you see something really
interesting that your predictions has
been made over there so I guess this is
not showing any V visualization because
of some my error so you see that your
mean is standard deviation of
predictions is this right so actually it
made the predictions out there okay I
hope it makes sense now we have deployed
the model made the predictions too now
you might be thinking here how can I
make the single handle had single handle
predictions right so we are done with
the deployment and inference as well now
it is actually making good uh inference
out there it is actually predicting but
it might happen that you're still
confused so let's just not have too much
of confusion in your head and then fix
that confusion too so I have actually
made um simple streamlet
dot send it app dop appy
okay paste
it right right I hope it works mostly so
you from the deployment pipeline it
Imports the prediction service loader
and then run
deployment from run deployment it
Imports let's make it main rather than R
right Main
and then over here as
main okay so everything is same the only
thing which is if the sub person clicks
the predict button it will go to the
prediction service gives this and then
it says that if the post service is
there then creates the DAT data frame
does the same step which which we have
data and predictor and predict from the
data right so let's run the
streamlit Run streamlet
app.py please
run fair enough high level overview is
not there so I'll just make sure that I
remove all the
images
okay any
images M
okay let's run it
[Music]
now let's wait is it is
running cool so I'll just make it z z
everything so it's now it giv prediction
so basically your detail is 4.22 so
basically it is actually using the
production from the model so you see
that we haven't even saved the model
save saved the model is not there it's
actually using it it's actually the
pipelines over there if you go and see
the pipelines of our so let's go to
pipelines and then let's go to
continuous deployment pipeline The
Continuous deployment pipeline you have
the following inference pipeline which
is done right and then let's go
behind back okay let's just go
continuous deployment continuous
deployment continuous deployment and in
that continuous deployment you see the
continuous deployment is also there
right so whole P pipeline is done so we
are done with one project right I hope
it was really good project for you uh I
understand it cool so let's just go
ahead and then that's it that's the app
of the project in the next project we'll
actually use something known as customer
CH or maybe let's cover the next project
up to catch you later bye-bye